This is Jocko podcast number one 52 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Yeah.
These are men that would rather die than live with the shame that they didn't
offer their last breath in service to the men,
to their left and to the right in battle.
Each man was shaped through immense trials,
personal fortitude and dedication,
giving all he had to offer
at times when only the great pride of walking in the path least traveled was
there to keep him company
through constant discipline,
drive and sacrifice.
They have risen to the top of their trade and embodied the ethos of the Marine
Raider.
A man who displays the very pinnacle of Soldiery Virtue and Unwavering Loyalty.
A man who will never quit or surrender and who,
uh,
who will at all times stand ready to sacrifice whatever is needed to accomplish
the mission.
They stand as shiny examples of what our nation in trusts.
It's freedom and respect too.
Nothing is more on inspiring.
Then the look on a fellow operators face as they are surrounded by death,
the casual smile of confidence as they acknowledge that things will be what
they'll be.
And if this is the way we die,
then let's do it right and honor our legacy.
Okay.
When surrounded on all sides,
we faced what seemed the inevitability of death,
not a man before you skipped a beat and their commitment.
Yeah.
All or nothing.
Death or glory.
And those are some excerpts from a speech by Marine Raider Gunnery Sergeant
Brian.
See Jacqueline talking about a mission that he was on heroin.
I think in that speech he did a great job of explaining the type of man that
makes up the marine Raiders,
which is the marine core component of special operations.
And tonight we are lucky enough to be sitting with one of those men,
a United States
marine,
a special operations radar and a true Herro Derek Herrera.
Okay,
Derek,
welcome man.
Thanks for coming on.
Thanks for having me.
It's a pleasure to be here.
It's awesome to have you on here,
man.
I know we got hooked up through some,
uh,
old mutual friends and I'm glad we did.
And I'm glad to sit down and be able to talk to you and hear a little bit about
you and your life and everything that you've done.
And as usual,
let's start in a,
let's start in Little Rock,
Arkansas.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
We're just where you were born,
right?
I was born in Little Rock,
Arkansas and Wah Wah Wah.
Like what was the family doing in Little Rock,
Arkansas?
My father was a pilot in the air force.
Okay.
And so we were stationed there and I was born there in 1984.
And,
and then how long were you guys moving around all the time?
Typical military family?
Yes,
absolutely.
So moved about every two or three years.
So I lived in Arkansas for about two years,
moved to Illinois,
I think for a year or two.
And then,
uh,
Honduras,
for an overseas assignment to go see all the Honduras in the late eighties,
which was pretty interesting.
Do you speak Spanish then?
No,
I,
I did for a while and then tried to replace it with Arabic and then Pashto and
yeah,
I learned that it's not one of my gifts.
Let's just go with English and get a terp.
Exactly.
Uh,
so knew enough to be tactically conversing,
you know,
but um,
but now,
so live there for a few years.
And then,
uh,
my dad moved to Dover,
Delaware was stationed at Dover Air Force Base.
He was a c one 30 and c five pilot and uh,
continue to bounce around.
But at that time in elementary school,
my parents are divorced,
so my family still lives in Delaware today.
Also the opportunity to live in Colorado and a few other places.
But at what,
at what age were you when you got sorta like the military bug in your head?
It was always a family business.
So my grandfathers were both in the Air Force for 25 years and 28 years
respectively.
They were enlisted in the air force.
Um,
and my father was an air force for 22 years in active duty.
How did you get knocked?
Get Bit by the Air Force Bug was interesting.
So go through high school.
Uh,
I'd always knew I wanted to serve in the military,
um,
and started to get interested in the surface academy a option as well.
So when I lived in Colorado,
actually made,
I was,
I loved my dad when he was stationed at the Air Force Academy.
So we get on the Air Force Academy when I was there for seventh and eighth grade
and uh,
just always was drawn to that line of work and a desire to air force academy is,
that's a nice environment.
I really nice.
It's a really nice environment.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
And,
and your dad was working there and that it seemed,
it was that not,
I mean,
when you say you were thinking about the,
the military academies,
were you thinking of the Air Force Academy as your primary or no.
Uh,
so after that experience,
um,
in ninth grade,
I moved back with my mom in high school in Delaware and,
uh,
my senior year of high school,
um,
had been playing lacrosse up to that point and had the opportunity to go and
play for navy,
uh,
or try to walk on at least,
and had decent relationship with the coaches there.
Um,
and so I was applying to navy and air force and,
uh,
also want it to be a navy seal actually.
And so,
um,
at that time I wanted to go to the naval academy.
And so as soon as I got in and got accepted there,
uh,
stopped applying other places and just decided to go there.
Yeah,
right on.
Yeah.
When did you visit the Naval Academy?
Do you know what was going on at the Naval Academy?
The only reason I asked that is because like,
I mean,
I know I was not the most squared away kid.
I was kind of a rebellious kid and even though I love the military,
I think if I would have gone to,
and I went to west point when I was a little kid and that Kinda got me fired up,
you know,
I think my dad took me to some kind of game there.
I mean,
I was really young,
like maybe seven or eight or something like that,
but it was enough to make me go.
Yeah.
You know,
I kind of,
but I think if I saw it when I was a little bit older,
I dunno,
I think I would have just said like,
I don't know if I can put up with all that right now.
Yeah,
but you did.
You were like,
I'm,
I'm bringing it,
you know,
17 year old young man,
uh,
doesn't always have all the right motivations.
Uh,
and you know,
you have all the reasons why you go to a place like that.
And what I found after I had gone there was that,
uh,
those reasons change once you're there.
And so I entered in 2002,
uh,
shortly after September 11th.
Uh,
it wasn't solely out of patriotic duty and every,
you know,
and those sorts of things.
It was because,
you know,
I had already gotten in,
uh,
I'd wanted to play lacrosse there.
Uh,
I was in love with my high school sweetheart from Delaware,
who's now still my wife of almost 13 years.
Um,
and so those were the reasons why it initially,
you know,
decided,
yeah,
how did that play?
How did you have in your high school sweetheart,
how did that play in to want to go into the Naval Academy?
Because you would be close by.
It was about an hour drive away so she could come and see me on the weekend and
that kind of stuff.
And,
uh,
and so those were some of the initial reasons why I went there.
In addition,
all the,
the patriotic reasons as well.
But,
uh,
what I found when I was there,
and you're challenged and you're tested,
is those smaller,
superficial motivators often fade away,
right?
And what you're left with is those reasons why I initially went here aren't
going to continue to propel me through the rest of this trial.
Right?
And so the motivation and the things that I learned from there at that point
was,
uh,
the seniors that,
we'd watched and,
and were led by,
uh,
who had just graduated.
We're literally going forward and leading marines and sailors in battle.
And we literally watch that on television with the invasion of Iraq and,
and the,
the things going on in Afghanistan and uh,
really bought into the entire leadership philosophy and,
and
wanting to be a part of that and want it to be that and follow that example.
So those are the reasons why I tried to stay and continue to move forward and
become a military officer.
I always,
lately I've been like apologizing to people because there's actually been a
pretty decent number of people that have joined the military because of
listening to,
you know,
all of us guys that bring on here talk about their experiences and they just
think that sounds pretty cool.
I always say,
hey,
just don't be mad at me like the first two weeks that you're going through boot
camp or whatever.
Don't be mad.
Cause it's just,
it's like not,
it's going to be a shock to your system when you lose all that freedom that
you've had.
And,
but I,
I totally agree with you in the fact that like once you get through that initial
shock and you realize that there's a longterm thing going on here and you want
to be a part of it,
that's,
yeah,
that's awesome.
And especially for you guys that came in after September 11th,
because that's a,
that's a,
I don't know if people can appreciate that,
what the difference is between the pre September 11th and post September 11th.
I mean pre September 11th,
there was almost,
in fact,
my first deployment to Iraq,
my seal platoon had zero combat experience,
zero zero.
So no one had any combat experience at all.
The most things that anyone had done at that point was doing shit boardings in
the Persian Gulf,
which are not combat experience.
It's just,
uh,
it's just,
fairly administrative operation.
And now every single guy,
every single guy in the seal teams has combat expenses.
Every single guy.
Well,
I mean barring maybe a few outliers,
but basically every single guy,
you know,
the Marine Corps,
look at the Marine Corps right now.
I mean it's been,
it's been what,
17 years of fighting and the combat experience is just so incredible compared to
prior to September 11th which it was totally rare to have somebody at a seal
team that was in the first Gulf War that was in one of the three platoons that
got to do something.
And,
and what they did,
you know,
God bless them,
they were doing their duty,
but it wasn't these big long sustained combat operations.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
And I think that's something that you know,
I think about a lot today,
especially when we talk about millennials and everything else and they get a bad
rep,
but everybody knows what they're joining the military to do.
Like,
and some men and women run to the sound of the gun and some don't.
And so the people that continue to stay,
and like there was no question of what,
what you were doing if you sign up to join the Marine Corps or the seals.
Right.
Like,
and then how did that selection process,
you said you wanted to possibly go in the seal teams.
How did that work out that you didn't go in the seal teams and that's gotta be a
tough decision to make.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
sometimes it's made for you,
right?
So,
uh,
naval academy is a very,
very humbling experience.
Um,
and so as I came out of high school,
I was kind of a very talented young athlete and you know,
uh,
was able to get in.
Um,
but I was also from a small town and,
you know,
it didn't have
the humility and,
and ownership,
uh,
needed to be a part of the teams.
And,
uh,
that became readily apparent.
Y'All,
I was physically capable,
but just wasn't mature enough,
honestly.
Uh,
and wasn't,
you know,
didn't have that right mindset.
So it was thoroughly humbled.
And then as I was kind of,
you know,
coming to the realization of what I wanted to do with my life,
what,
what now,
uh,
you know,
had a mentor of mine who I really respected,
uh,
who was a marine major and said,
you know,
Derek Lik I can help you try to get in the Marine Corps if you're still wanting
to do that.
And that's what you want to,
I think you'd make a great officer.
And,
um,
you know,
the Marine Corps that you see at the naval academy is not what is the reality,
right,
of what the fleet does.
Because I had a really bad taste for marines there because all the marines ever
drill instructors and it was their job to mess with you.
And,
uh,
so I was like,
man,
reigns are dumb.
I don't want to be like that.
Um,
but the more I got to know the reality of what it was like in the fleet and
what,
what real marines were doing,
uh,
decided to pursue it and absolutely loved it and it was the best thing for me.
And did you get,
so then you go from there too,
from the academy,
go to the basic school,
correct.
Yeah.
So we go to the basic school,
we go for the six months of,
of the basic school and,
uh,
with evergreen officer.
So every marine officer,
ground air,
everybody goes through that same process.
And then during that time,
there's another selection.
Uh,
so,
you know,
literally rank every choice you have from the tanks,
supply,
logistics,
finance,
I like one through 21,
if you're a ground officer or if your pilot,
obviously you have a flight contract,
you don't have to do that,
but you rank it and then they do a quality spread to determine what you get.
So in some cases,
uh,
pre nine 11,
like you said,
it was,
it was really hard and competitive to become an infantry officer.
Uh,
and then when we were there,
um,
it was still pretty competitive until about halfway through the course,
or just give me like a month out from the end of the course because manpower
came down and was like,
we're standing up a new infantry regiment.
So boom.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
so I think I would've gotten infantry regardless,
but,
uh,
either way.
Got what I wanted.
It was my first choice and that's exactly what I wanted to do and move forward.
And then where'd you,
where'd you go from from there?
Where'd you,
she's saying Quantico for a three month course called infantry officer's course
gets on and it's amazing.
Yeah.
One of the best training experiences there are.
And so you learn weapon systems,
you learn,
you know,
every,
all,
all different kinds of basic small unit tactics,
everything you need to be able to lead a rifle platoon in an infantry battalion.
Yeah.
I don't know if you,
yeah,
you said you listened to the podcast with Jim Webb on it and like his first of
all.
And so then you went to a battalion and then you started to work up.
Yeah.
And all that.
Jim Webb went from that school to Vietnam and they like brought him out in the
field and dropped him off and said,
there's your platoon over there.
The guy you're replacing is no longer with us and you're going to go take over
that battalion.
And he walked up on the side a hill and said,
hey,
how you doing?
I'm Lieutenant Webb and here's what we're going to do.
And,
and then that night they got a big firefight and he called in combined arms and
man,
but that school must be,
must be an awesome school,
but it's pretty amazing.
And by the time we were there,
we had really phenomenal leaders and instructors who are able to teach us
because they were fresh off the battlefield in Iraq and a rebel to teach us
exactly what we were going to do.
And so for me,
I went into a long workup prior to deploying,
but some of our guys were just like,
what happened to Jim Webb?
No kidding.
They had maybe a month or meeting their platoon at their final exercise as
they're stepping off to,
to go to Iraq.
And so that's no joke,
right?
There was,
yeah,
it was pretty interesting.
And so,
um,
for me,
you know,
I ended up going to a new battalion that was standing up First Battalion Eighth
Marines,
uh,
the walking dead and,
had about a year roughly to work in local tune in and to train before we ended
up deploying to Iraq.
Yeah.
And that was just a standard ground pounder,
infantry platoon initially.
Yes.
Yeah.
And so we were a standard rifle tune and then about two months before deployment
based on the needs of the situation in
Ramadi,
we're redeploying to,
uh,
the decision was made to actually break us down into smaller training teams and
advisory teams.
And so my platoon of roughly 40 marines and sailors turned into two 12 man
teams,
uh,
which I was in charge of wine and my platoon sergeant was in charge of another
one.
And so the reason they did that was because that was roughly the minimum size
required to partner with,
uh,
effectively for these police stations.
And so at that time,
due to the,
uh,
the successes of people like yourself and the other people that had fought in
Ramadi and turn the tide of the battle,
uh,
we were consolidating and basically,
you know,
withdrawing a lot of the combat power.
And so we took over for two different infantry battalions that,
another army unit with just one infantry retired.
So we had the entire
area of operations for just one time.
And so I had a initially one police station that I was partnered with,
you know,
as a young lieutenant in a 12 man team.
We were partnered with,
uh,
an Iraqi colonel and over 800 Iraqi police.
Um,
whereabouts were you wearing his,
we were in a small neighborhood,
just south of Camper Monte called Tamim.
Okay.
So all of to meme,
we were managing with the police there because the police had done such a good
job and taken over,
uh,
yeah,
we were in the backseat.
Yeah,
totally.
Just to give everyone a tooth,
this is 2008,
right?
Correct.
So the major fighting kind of tapered off in,
in
Oh seven.
I mean,
early oh seven,
they were pretty,
it was pretty calm.
I know the guys that relieved us by the time they laughed,
it was very common.
Ramadi,
um,
you know,
obviously there's still always going to be a,
but like to me
when we were there,
there was,
there was a lot,
there was a really bad,
big,
gnarly iads into me when we were there.
And it was,
it was,
uh,
yeah,
it was awful.
Some of the,
some of those Humvees would get hit and it would just be,
you know,
they'd lose three,
four,
five guys at a,
at a shot.
It was a,
it was horrible,
but,
you know,
that's awesome.
And that's,
I always tried to explain to people that,
that in Ramadi we actually won.
And you,
you know,
you're proof of that when you were over there and you guys were,
I'm sure doing the civil affairs and,
you know,
that type of thing.
Is that basically what you were doing?
Yeah,
we were,
you know,
just really just trying to turn it over,
uh,
to the police there.
And so got to sit on,
you know,
the weekly Sheroes and the council meetings and hang out and drink tea with the
current hall.
Um,
and we try to try to do operations with them and everything,
but they lock the place down.
I mean,
literally by the time we were there they had,
you know,
triple strand,
concertina wire and check points all around the entire cities.
They were controlling the flow of that prevented the flow of any,
you know,
any material or any fighters.
So that then it did such a good job that honestly,
um,
I don't think anybody shot at us the entire deployment.
We've got a few different smaller ideas here and there.
We had one major incident with a vehicle borne IED that killed a lot of our
Iraqi policemen,
unfortunately.
Um,
but none of our Americans were involved or had gotten,
gotten injured at that time.
Um,
but they were very well trained,
uh,
fighting force and you know,
they did good work.
How was it setting the expectations for your 19 year old marines that was,
that were,
you know,
on deployment with you that we're expecting to go get some yeah,
that was interesting.
So you gotta you gotta
deal with the missions that you're,
you're given,
right.
And so,
um,
the average 19 year old lance corporal or 18 year old lance corporal at that
time,
uh,
you know,
sign up to join to go fight.
Yeah.
That wasn't our mission.
And so we were very cognizant of that.
And over the year,
the workup,
we were well educated too.
So we had direct comes with the teams we were turning over with over a
classified email network and those sorts of things.
And we're able to find out exactly what we'd be going into.
You were able to manage those expectations appropriately.
Yeah.
And because of that we were,
we were successful.
I think our teams performed well.
You know,
they're obviously frustrated at times,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
I can kind of,
I would have guys ask me that,
you know,
guys,
once I was,
while I was back when I was still in,
but guys would say,
you know,
how am I supposed to get guys fired up to do this mission when it's all we're
going to be doing is drinking tea.
And you know,
I'd say,
listen,
that's,
that's still your mission and you have to do it to the best of your ability and
get the Iraqi police train up as much as best you can.
And you still have to just attack it with everything you've got regardless of
what that mission is.
And,
and that's,
hey man,
that's,
that's what,
that's what the nation is calling on you to do is that right there.
And so go do to the best of your ability.
And that's again,
you know,
that's why I asked you that question because believe me,
you get these young kids,
man,
they don't want to have tea with anybody.
I just want to shoot their right.
Yeah,
no,
we're pretty fortunate.
And we did do some interesting things
as well.
So,
uh,
because we had access and placement within the neighborhood,
um,
to me was kind of a pretty tightly packed urban area and a lot of people would
come and go.
Uh,
and so at that time we had great intelligence networks.
They would able,
we're able to help,
you know,
help us identify if somebody didn't belong.
And we were able to work with our counterparts to,
to try to intervene before they were able to,
uh,
cause any issues.
And so we rounded up for a few different,
uh,
raids,
which,
you know,
kept,
uh,
kept the guns motivated and things.
But,
um,
but it's kind of a good and bad thing,
right?
That,
you know,
there was no,
no fight going on in that regards.
A good in the sense that,
you know,
the guys are safe and came back and were able to have a successful deployment.
It's still do something really meaningful for the country,
but you know,
not as,
as exciting as they would have wanted because that's what the 18 year old signs
up to join,
to go do,
you know,
volunteers to do.
Yeah.
I don't think too many guys walking in that recruiter's office thinking about,
you know,
police actions or anything like that.
But yeah,
but that's,
but you have to set their expectations correctly.
And then it sounds like you were able to do that.
Now when you came home from that deployment,
you,
you deployed again,
but it was like even more,
it was even more on a humanitarian side.
So what was that like?
Well,
tell us about that one
other stuff too.
So before I had actually a deployed,
again when I came back at such a good experience and learned about Marsoc at
that time,
the Marine Special Operations Command that did selection,
uh,
in between those two,
deployments was selected.
And so,
uh,
at that time,
the criteria to get into mar soc was you had to do two deployments.
And so I had to go back and train and then deploy again.
So wait,
so the s selection like buds for Marsoc,
is that what it is?
Kind of.
It's more
w we follow more of a Greenbrae army model.
So it's modeled very,
very similarly to,
uh,
the special forces assessment selection process.
How long is the,
the training?
It's about six weeks.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you go there and you do,
you know,
the basic tasks associated with selection,
including,
you know,
hiking a lot and land nav and psychological screenings is more of like a weeding
out.
Are they actually training you for anything?
Uh,
yeah,
there's no,
I wouldn't say there's really much of training.
It's a lot of critical thinking and problem solving and,
and very similar to the,
as fast as far as like,
you know,
here's problem set,
ethical problem set and physical problems said teamwork and you're continually
being evaluated.
Um,
but that's just a basic evaluation to just get the at going to
like go into our training course.
And so then we have a seven month law.
Okay,
I got it.
So first can we go through is just a selection to see if you're going to be able
to go through the real course?
Yeah.
Okay.
Got It.
Yeah.
Bud's doesn't do that.
You just show up there.
And that's what,
that's one of the reasons the attrition rate's so high.
Maybe if we had them pre,
and actually I take that back now they do have like a pre,
you go to like a pre buds and you get prepared for it and all that.
But um,
so you go to that selection and you get picked up.
So you go through that thing and they pick you up but then you haven't done two
deployments.
They go,
no,
you still got to go on an appointment again.
Yeah.
And that deployment ends up being a humanitarian deployment for the most part.
Yeah,
definitely.
So we did what was called the Marine Expeditionary Unit and so on the Marine
Expeditionary Unit there are marines and Bark and bark,
the board naval vessels and so there's a battalion infantry battalion.
I come too.
I did too,
a mew,
our deployments back in the day.
So I was out there with all,
all the boys getting after it.
That's how I've developed a bunch of,
you know,
have a bunch of friends that were in the Marine Corps in recon and force recon
from that time from doing arg deployments.
So yeah,
we,
we got our shipboard time,
but we used to conceal his uncle don't really do that too much anymore,
but no,
no.
And Yeah,
and I think that's a good thing.
Um,
it was tough.
That was,
that was pretty tough,
you know,
it was to talk about motivating your team to stay motivated through seven months
of shaking hands and drinking tea and Iraq and now it's,
hey,
stay ready and just train on a ship where,
you know,
you have no room,
you don't have any real ability to train.
The Gym holds six people and there's three treadmills and you can't get on the
flight deck for,
you know,
whatever,
two hours a day and kind of ship were you on?
So I was on,
uh,
the LPD 19.
I was in Mesa Verde.
It was nicer.
It was newer ship.
So it was nice and it was good because we were on the,
it was a smaller ship,
so we weren't on the major,
the big flat top with the command.
And so,
um,
so it was pretty good.
And,
and I had a great deployment because I was the company executive officer and so
I got to spend very little time on the ship,
which was a lot of fun because you got to go and a plan,
all the training.
And so,
uh,
you know,
we were bouncing around doing different bilateral training missions with,
uh,
Israel,
Jordan Amman,
uh,
trained in Kuwait,
had some liberty time and cut her by renting.
Uh,
all of the peaceful countries in Middle East said.
So it was,
it was good.
It was a really good experience.
Um,
but you know,
a lot of marines hate it because they were stuck on the ship.
They didn't have the luxury that I did to go and get off the ship and,
and train.
And so it was,
uh,
it was interesting deployment.
Yeah.
Those shipboard deployments are,
um,
very interesting.
They were like,
we would do that really dumb stuff.
First of all,
when I was on shipboard deployments,
there was no internet,
there was nothing.
So
we,
we was mailing.
Yeah.
And I mean we were just dumb and so we would watch,
we had,
you know,
a big box full of video tapes.
Do you know what those are?
Yeah.
Yes.
Video cassettes.
Because there was no whatever,
streaming Netflix.
So we just add like auditor,
we probably watched 20 movies 5,000 times each.
So that era of movies I'm very familiar with.
But,
but yeah,
and it was like,
you know,
the big joke about seals is when you're on a ship is sleep,
eat and lift.
That's what it stands for,
to sleep,
eat and left.
Cause that's all there is to do.
And,
but we would,
we would PT every day out on the flight deck or somewhere on the ship.
And then we would try and set up where we'd go shoot skeet,
we brawn and pallets and pallets worth of skeet.
So we'd go on the back,
the fantail the ship and throw skeet,
shoot it.
Or We'd sit out there with grenade launchers and launch grenades at the sh the
trash as,
so we try and make it fun,
you know,
but still there's 24 hours in a day and there's not a lot to do on a ship.
Yeah.
So it's was very pretty boring.
And um,
yeah,
and for all the listeners to the,
that was the,
the reality pre nine 11,
before there were all these deployments that was,
you know,
you're just so the,
the mission for the [inaudible],
it was just a what
to be prepared in a crisis.
It's crisis response force essentially.
And so for us,
we actually had the opportunity to do one real world mission responding to the
earthquake in Haiti,
which was like you said,
a humanitarian assistance and disaster relief.
And so,
um,
right off the bat,
as we were getting underway,
uh,
that had happened a couple of weeks before we were scheduled deployed.
So we got on and went down and were able to,
uh,
get involved and help out.
So we just flew in with the company Marines and our company was tasked with just
helping provide an establish security for a forward staging base.
So logistics area,
uh,
for some of the food and water that they were distributing.
So how bad was it down there?
Pretty terrible.
Uh,
it was really,
really bad.
Um,
we were fluid on a helicopter,
uh,
into the giant dirt field,
which,
you know,
we were bouncing,
see wire and set on fire plants,
sketches and everything just to,
to get everything squared away.
But the level of poverty was pretty,
pretty striking for,
uh,
for us.
I mean,
we had a marine standard post and San and guard and everything and you know,
you see for homeless kids between the age eight and 12 sleeping with,
you know,
everything they own and they're,
they're sharing one blanket outside the wire just hanging out,
you know,
uh,
we see like a fist fight,
a drag knockout,
drag down,
fist fight between two girls that are age,
whatever,
12 and 14 over a piece of wood.
Because firewood is like gold.
There is,
they just don't have wood.
And so that was really,
really eye opening experience for us.
And so what were you guys doing?
Are you guys bringing water?
You bring in medical care and what were you doing?
So,
uh,
the UN was administering all the food and water and so they basically dropped us
off and a typical marine corps fashion,
they said,
uh,
you know,
pack light,
you'll only be in there for 24 hours before we relieve you.
And then,
uh,
as we get on the bird,
they're like,
okay,
it might be like 48,
and uh,
by the time we land.
And they were like,
we're not sure what you're getting out.
So,
um,
so you got to stand for about nine days.
And I had to beg,
borrow and steal things there,
but our job was just to literally make sure that,
you know,
overnight they could drop off 60 shipping trailers,
ISO containers of food and water,
and that people weren't gonna who distributed the food and water.
It was primarily the,
you enforced there.
So I think at that time it was a lot of,
uh,
I think it was a primary Brazilian force.
And so they would come in in the morning and his load up and go and distributed.
And I know that was different for a lot of other places,
but for us that was,
that was the mission that we had.
And that was the kind of the way it worked.
So it was a very short temporary stint and then got back on the ships and
steamed across the Atlantic
and then,
and then hit all a bunch of exercises and whatnot.
Like you sat over in the golf.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
unfortunately we didn't get to do the exercise we'd planned for Israel because
we're in Haiti instead.
So we went straight to,
I think it was Jordan.
Uh,
we did,
uh,
infinite moonlight,
I think at that time.
Um,
and we're able to do some basic patrolling with Jordanian soldiers.
That was kind of cool actually because,
uh,
not only is Jordan just a amazing country to be in,
but,
um,
those people that were training with were some of the same units that we're
going to fight in Afghanistan.
Okay.
And so the Jordanians provided,
uh,
a good contingent of forces to go,
go forward in Afghanistan.
So that was,
that was fun.
I'm getting to work with those guys in the train with those guys.
And then we trained with,
uh,
Omani and soldiers and that was pretty interesting as well.
Um,
the thing we learned,
which was really interesting was,
uh,
actual Omanis.
There's not three of a really small population,
so they have,
uh,
at least the units that we were working with had some,
some conscripts from uh,
Pakistan essentially Baluchistan.
Um,
and so the officers spoke Arabic and they were Omani but the rest of the platoon
was all Bellucci and you know,
spoke,
uh,
Bellucci.
And so that was kinda interesting to see how that worked.
But,
uh,
you know,
very capable force had a good time no kid fight with those guys.
And so,
yeah,
Modern Day conscripts.
Yeah,
and I mean,
they all volunteer.
I mean,
they,
I guess taking the concert might not be the right word.
They all volunteered to be there.
And so we talked to girl platoon sergeant and he's like,
hey,
so it's like a wave in here for money and get a better life for themselves.
So he's like,
Hey,
the deal is I've been here for 20 years,
I love doing this job.
I'm able to send money home back to my family and if I make it to 30,
they'll let me bring my family over here.
So again,
see his family
and 20 years.
But he's,
you know,
trying to better their lot in life by going forward to,
live and fight for another country watch.
You can't,
can't fault him for that.
Like,
that's not what I want to work with.
All right,
so you get home,
you get home from that deployment and now it's time to go to,
what's the,
what's the long course of Mar Soc?
What's that course called?
It's called individual training course.
And so it is a pretty similar to other special forces training courses.
So where is it?
It's in North Carolina.
Okay.
I can't believe June.
Uh,
and so we have a small,
uh,
portion of the base there.
Now we've established the a pretty sizable compound.
And so I'd say probably 80 to 90% of the Marine Special Operations Command as is
headquartered there.
And then they have a small west coast contingent out here at Camp Pendleton.
And so the entire school house is there and that's where every operator goes
through training.
And how long is that course?
It's about seven,
eight months.
Now what are you doing in that course?
So that is of course,
that encompasses all of the basic fundamentals required to join a team and to be
an operator.
So we do,
the first phase is some physical training.
Uh,
you know,
you do some basic fire support,
some medical training,
you do your sear,
uh,
your full spectrum sere training there.
Uh,
and then you move into some basic,
uh,
Sr in patrolling special reconnaissance and basic,
you know,
uh,
reconnaissance skills,
our guys this,
so this isn't really a selection course then.
I mean,
you know,
this is a training course,
but,
but like,
but it's pretty high stakes too.
And guys are quitting her quit.
Yeah.
Plenty of guys quit real.
It's not easy.
Uh,
so we kind of,
uh,
it just,
it the way,
you know,
it just seems like if someone was a marine already and then they made it through
that first course and now they show up at this course,
it seems like that's,
that's a lot of hoops to jump through to get to there and then quit.
That seems kind of a little bit crazy.
Yeah.
Well we had some great instructors and,
uh,
they,
they pushed us hard ride to try to break us.
What did they do it,
what is it like the same?
Is it like the buds type stuff be called beware,
be tired,
be measurable?
No sleep is just to get some of that.
Yeah,
for the most part,
uh,
kind of a mix of buds and SQT probably mixed together.
And so,
um,
one of the things that they are able to do with within Marsoc is to try to take
lessons learned and best practices from all of the other services.
And so whether it was,
you know,
the Q course or bloods or SQT or OTC or anything else,
the instructors kind of looked at what was going on in other courses and looked
at the requirement for marine Raiders,
uh,
coming out the backside.
Um,
cause some of those guys will graduate and we had guys deploy within a month or
two later on,
hot fills up to go operate.
So do they put you through like another like crucible type scenario?
Yeah.
So it was,
it kind of makes a,
it's called Raider Spirit and oh that's,
that sounds real fun.
That's one
of those things like we would get you with a little bit of that raider spirit
come and get some,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's a,
a varying length depending upon the class and the size and the performance.
But uh,
at that point you're trained in,
uh,
your amphib package,
your basic small boat handling.
Uh,
you're trained in basic reconnaissance and in those principles,
all your comms and everything else.
So it's basically a full foot full mission profile for,
you know,
including an amphibious insert,
which for us was,
I think like January gets,
so maybe.
And so,
uh,
and then same thing,
you know,
limited sleep,
limited water and limited food type thing.
So pretty,
pretty intense.
Yeah.
It just seems like a super,
a burnt the Marine Corps squared away and that's this whole thing.
Sounds like a squared away way to do this because if you look at Budz,
you even have real guns,
most of buds,
you don't even have rifles you're carrying,
you're literally carrying a boat paddle.
They kind of make that your weapon because you can't lose it and you can't put
it down all this stuff.
But it's a boat paddle I need,
you're just,
you're so,
you're just so young and untrained,
you know,
you,
you have no skills and so there's no,
it's just,
and they teach you,
you know,
when you get to land warfare,
you teach,
you learn some basic dining,
but the diving that you learn is just so,
so
easy.
Like looking back on it,
it's just the easiest possible things you could possibly do.
Diving.
And the same thing with the land warfare pieces.
Like they're telling you,
hey,
walk this far and they're telling you exactly where to go.
It's not even,
it's barely that you do land nav,
but it's barely land nav and it's,
and it's good because you know,
it weeds out a lot of people,
but then you have to go through,
like you said,
SQT which comes afterwards and that's where you start learning,
okay,
this is real land Nav.
Okay,
this is real shooting.
this is,
you know,
actual real mentorees.
And then you get to a seal team where you go through more training.
But it seems like it,
that's why I was Kinda,
I guess I was kind of surprised that guys that had been through enough stuff
already would get to that and still be like,
oh,
you know,
I don't want to do this.
That seems crazy to me.
Yeah,
that's a gut check.
I mean,
um,
and that's one of the things that,
uh,
is interesting.
You know,
bud's does a good job at weeding people out up front.
Uh,
and so you have a pretty high quality care,
you know,
as far as the intangibles,
the ethical and character principles.
Um,
and then for us,
you know,
it's a kind of,
I would say more on a sustained
[inaudible] beat down.
Yeah.
And so,
I mean,
we started,
I think we started the course with like 50 or 60 guys and 13 of the original guy
finished,
you know,
and so that's changed a lot since then.
So we've grown up a lot since then.
And just like Bod Taz,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I bet back in the day those,
those new mar soc instructors,
like no one's getting through my course.
Yeah.
And rightfully so.
Um,
but the cool thing about it,
no,
I see both sides of the token.
But,
uh,
the cool thing about it now is that we want more god,
we need more guns.
Yeah.
We don't wanna lower the standards,
so why don't we just be smarter about it,
right.
Like,
if we do a better job of selecting guides or get more guys starting or whatever
else,
right.
Like if the output is a trained operator and we need,
need these guys then was there any part of that training that you thought was
hard?
Yeah,
a lot of it was hard.
Was there anything that you were in jeopardy on where it was like,
same thing,
right?
So hum.
Yeah,
Naval Academy was humbling be in the Marine Corps has been humbling.
And uh,
at that point I was a pretty humble guy.
Um,
and so I did really well throughout the majority of training.
And,
uh,
so in the last phase,
all feeling good about yourself,
I was okay.
But I said,
you know,
so we were doing the unconventional warfare package,
very similar to,
uh,
very similar,
with the green berets do with their final exercise and flowing with the g force
and everything else.
And so it was doing well.
And then,
uh,
had a bad meeting where somebody thought I came off a little bit arrogant with
our g force commander and everything.
And so then they just Kinda,
you know,
put the spotlight on me and put me,
put me on the bubble.
Right.
Cause like you fail anything and you're done.
And so,
yeah,
that was one of the scarier times,
right?
Cause I had committed years of my life to be able to be doing this successfully.
And then in a moment,
you know,
if I can't figure out how to make this guy like me or this g force commander,
execute this mission with me,
like I'm on the bubble.
Right.
I think,
you know,
some of it's instructors mess around just they're,
they're just testing you,
right?
Like,
you know,
to see how are you going to,
how do you deal with failure?
Right?
Because if you've been successful thus far in a,
a good number of things,
uh,
let's push them beyond as limit.
Let's break them and see what happens.
Right.
And,
and I don't know if that was exactly the case.
I didn't see behind the curtain,
but I survived.
I failed something called pool competency.
Mm.
And I failed pool competency,
which is they put,
they put your dive rig on,
which is an old school dive rig with a,
with an inhalation and exhalation tube.
And it's this and this old thing from like the sixties or seventies or
something,
aqua lung.
And,
uh,
you have to do all this stuff that they tell you to do underwater and they're,
they're slapping you around and smashing you and ripping your mask off and rest,
ripping the regulator out in all this stuff and you have to stay calm and you
have to go through all these procedures.
And when I went through it was a 30 minute evolution.
And,
uh,
the first time I did it,
my instructor who ended up working for me in the future,
he was a,
well,
he was a first class at the time,
but he became a warrant officer.
Breeza Udt Vietnam Guy,
an awesome guy.
But he failed me.
And um,
yeah.
And so I failed them.
Years later I talked to him and was like,
Hey,
do you remember putting me through Paul Glazier?
Yeah,
I was just messing with you.
I'm like,
oh,
you almost ruined my life.
Are you talking about your dismay?
He goes,
no,
I knew you do find next time.
Same thing.
Like it was a test of,
let's just see how this guy does,
but what we did over the weekend,
me and a couple buddies that were,
that had also failed.
We went in the dip tank,
which was just a square metal box and that was filled with water and we pool
comp to each other.
This,
I don't even,
I can't even believe we did this.
It was probably the most unsafe thing I've,
I did or one of the top unsafe things I did was we drown each other and trashed
each other getting ready and we did it to each other over and over again until
we were like,
there's no way we're going to fail.
And so that's what we did.
Like there's four of us or something who just spent the weekend in the,
I don't even,
I can't even believe they let us do that.
They just gave us dive gear and so you're just gonna play with the dive gear.
Cool.
We're in the dip tank link ads,
different time,
right?
Yeah.
But it is humbling and it's one of those things,
you know,
there's no worse feeling for me then that feeling of like,
Oh,
if I fail this,
this is,
this is like my whole life dream done and destroyed.
So yeah,
they make,
they play those,
uh,
they play those games with you and I think they have to play those games with
you because you're going to fail in other situations once you get to the,
to the teams,
you know,
you want it,
you do want to see how people are going to deal with failure.
And they would do things like that in bud's where,
you know,
they would,
there would be seven people that would pass a swim and everyone else is a
failure and they'd,
you know,
tell us needle,
they line us all up and make every single,
make a hundred guys sign a chit that we were losing her failures on the swim.
And if they fail,
if we fail again,
we're going to be dropped from training.
I don't think that was actually true.
I don't know.
But it didn't say looking back at the time,
I believed at the time I was like,
oh my God.
So they do a good job of that.
A psychological warfare on you when that training
before that too,
that you know another pretty intense phase.
So we did the CQB initial CQB phase,
uh,
prior to that too.
And so that one was same thing that was pretty high stakes,
pretty high,
you know,
high stress.
Did you mess up?
No,
I,
I was,
I was okay there.
Yeah.
I didn't have any issues but thrown rounds.
He shoot me any hostages?
Nah,
I shot a hostage one time.
Oh yeah,
I shot a hot just in training.
But yeah,
obviously just in training,
but this guy,
they had a target set up,
you know,
those,
they look like a water color painting targets that,
so there are different characters and you can take little,
you could take the person's hand and you could paste over like a pistol or a
cell phone or a badge or a whatever.
So I come into this room and it's,
it's kind of dusk and this was,
this was back in the day,
so we didn't even use night vision.
This is just like day,
you know,
we just shooting with our eyesight or regular eyesight and I come in and there's
a guy and I look at his hands and I see like a dark pipe pointed at me and I
drilled this dude,
you know,
to,
to the chest warranted
and we get done with a run and the instructor,
he comes out and he's like,
he's holding the target in his hands and he's like,
he's like,
Hey Jocko,
look at this.
And I was like,
check.
And he goes,
what do you see?
And what it was was it was allegedly,
it was a rolled up newspaper that he was pointing at the,
at the,
at you,
you know,
at me and it looked like of the barrel of a gun.
And I,
and I looked to the instructor,
I was like,
hey bro,
if I come into a room and someone's doing that,
they're going to die.
I'm sorry.
Maybe you can't do that.
Cause the guy looks all jacked.
He's this guy,
this guy with the green shirt.
I'm gonna find one of these and post it because I'm sure you can find them.
It's the guy with the green shirt,
super thick neck and looks all hostile and aggressive.
And he's pointing this pipe at me and I drilled him and I got in trouble.
That was my,
you know,
I had it,
whatever,
had to run a tire or something like that.
But um,
that was when I was in the teams that was,
you know,
hey,
yeah,
horrible.
Then you do,
you know,
even even though I was like,
Hey,
I'll do that anyways,
but inside and you know,
even though I was like,
man,
that,
you know,
you gotta be better than that.
And that was a,
that was jacked up for me to do that.
And so I had to check hands more carefully,
hadn't be more patient and taking that shot to make sure what I'm looking at is
what I'm looking at.
So yeah,
failure is a good teacher and it's very humbling.
And then,
so do you guys have like a full on graduation ceremony from that?
Do you get a hint?
Do you get that,
that new raider pity?
Yeah,
and we didn't have one at the time.
So we've,
uh,
we've grown up,
we weren't called Raiders and we didn't have a pen,
so we just got a little certificate and handshake and sent on her way.
And then you went to where?
Uh,
and then I was assigned to Camp Pendleton,
California.
So I moved out here with my wife and enjoyed First Marine Raider Battalion.
And uh,
and that was your first time being out at Pendleton,
correct?
Yeah.
How he liked Penelton.
I love it.
It's awesome.
It's still live here.
I didn't make it far,
even though my wife's family,
all her family is still in Delaware,
so we,
uh,
we love it here.
I hope to never lose its Pendleton.
Is,
is awesome training ground,
I mean,
really awesome training ground.
Yes.
Yeah,
it's great.
Great place to train.
Uh,
we did a lot of our training there and a typical places out in the desert in
Alec,
Fort Irwin and couple of other places.
But yeah,
it's,
it's good and it's massive.
I had no idea how big it was,
but just huge.
And then how long was that workup for?
We had saw arrived in August and I was in the three shop and the operations
section before I went to a team for about two months and then we deployed in
May,
so about nine months that I was with the team,
they had done their,
uh,
the workup cycle I think was probably similar to what the seal teams had done
where it's,
you know,
you come back,
you go back and you immediately guys are shotgunned out to schools,
individual training and then come back to collective training and then deploy.
So I had gotten there,
right one,
it was trickling back in from a lot of the individual schools that they were
going to.
And then how big is the team that you take over?
We had 20 total with attachments.
And so each team is about 14 or not about exactly 14.
Uh,
so there's,
you know,
small headquarters element and then,
uh,
two forming elements to a corpsman,
medics and,
um,
and then we plussed up with,
uh,
our Intel assets and EOD and,
gotten country,
got some dog antlers and some other stuff as well with our team.
And then,
and that,
when you say got in country,
this is,
this is you to,
you deployed to Afghanistan?
Yes.
Now it's 2012,
correct?
Yeah,
2012.
So I'd gotten out of training 2011 and then deployed in May of 2012.
And then what was that,
when you are going into that deployment,
what was the atmosphere in Afghanistan at that time?
The atmosphere was different depending upon the region you were in.
Very,
very different.
So,
uh,
where we were going was highly Connecticut,
a bad guy that's running around all over the place,
just kill or be killed and uh,
focusing a lot on security and combat operations.
Um,
and so there were two mission sets that our teams would,
uh,
would perform.
Uh,
either they would be doing a program called village stability operations,
which is what we were doing,
where they would be assigned to a commando can deck battalion,
which is more like Afghanistan's version of ranger regimen or anything else.
And so when we deployed,
we deployed a with the company,
so we had three marine teams.
One of our teams took over a commando mission and then the other two were doing
village stability operations.
Um,
and then as we,
uh,
deployed,
we took over a couple of seal units and uh,
Greenbrae team as well that reported to our,
our company headquarters as well.
So specifically for our team where we went,
we were in very,
very primitive rural area in the middle of the Helmand province,
uh,
right in the Green Zone.
And,
uh,
so the,
which Green Zone means something different in Afghanistan than it did in Iraq.
Green Zone in Iraq was an area in Baghdad actually that was,
that was controlled and safe and,
and all good to go for Americans.
And there was,
you know,
other people live in there and whatnot.
Is Exhibit a safe zone.
And the Green Zone in Afghanistan is not that.
No.
So the Green Zone in Afghanistan literally is,
uh,
due to vegetation.
And so the Green Zone,
Afghanistan is mostly arid or desert climate and there's very little green areas
are good farmland to essentially,
and I'm think it was in the 60s,
uh,
I think it was,
the USAID or another international development agency built another canal off of
the Helmand river.
And so in between those two waterways was good farmland cause uh,
farmers there would,
you know,
cut out canals and everything else to grow crops.
And so this was like one of the only green areas in the entire country.
Um,
it's,
that's what they,
they mean even the Afghanistan version of the green zone and sensitive
vegetation is also cover and concealment for fighters,
for enemy fighters.
Yeah.
And so where we were,
it was,
it was tough because guys would use those canals to sneak up and it was very
undulating,
are hilly terrain.
Um,
I would consider,
and when I talked tried to explain it to most people too,
I consider it more,
more similar to trench warfare then just desert open warfare where you can see
other people,
um,
people are very able to,
especially with some of the urban structures there as well.
Uh,
some of them he fires would be able to creep up and,
and you know,
try to get the drop on you and get close to your position.
So these V,
so you were doing VSL,
you the v village stability operations and what did that,
what did kind of,
what was your standard VSL mission look like?
What was that deal?
So for the VSO mission,
we had three lines of effort.
So the first was to establish security and the second was to try to revive
economic development.
And then the third was to link political governance.
So the three lines of effort,
security development and governance for political governance
couldn't really focus on economic development or political governance if the
villagers didn't have security.
And so one of the first things that we did,
and we took over a pretty capable force because people had been doing this
mission a lot before us in this region.
They would,
uh,
train and equip a small police force called the Afghan local police.
And so the idea was was if you take people in these small communities that are
from there,
train them,
pay them to prod security,
that they would be more effective at providing security than any Americans would
be.
Um,
which is in most cases very true.
And so we took over,
uh,
this site and we had about,
I think probably a hundred or more Afghans that run our payrolls to help go and
provide security for the area.
And so that was primarily what we focused on,
um,
because we were still trying to train them,
get them to a place where they could provide security for themselves.
This multiple villages in like an area that you're,
that you're providing security for,
that these Afghans are providing security,
or is it like one big,
you know,
like larger village?
For us,
it was just one village and it wasn't even,
I mean,
it wasn't even that big,
honestly.
So we literally,
uh,
as far as,
operational areas and things,
I think ours was a few kilometers Max.
So we were,
yeah,
because super focused where we were was,
um,
essentially a minefield to be right in the middle of this,
this contested region,
prime poppy,
growing,
uh,
area.
So Taliban wanted it and the farmers would grow poppy,
and that was their economic,
you know,
that was there.
Their payday,
their paychecks.
Um,
and so very complex problem to try to change.
Uh,
and so we,
so did you live in the villages?
Did you live there?
Yeah.
So you took over some houses or whatever,
and then you set up your,
your base of operations and you live there
essentially.
Yeah,
we took,
basically,
we weren't able to really take over any houses because all the houses that run
occupied world full of Ids.
So the TTP and base of what we had done at that time was,
uh,
wherever we were going to set up,
we would bulldoze and just build structures on our own.
You know,
Hasko barriers,
but it was very primitive.
We had no running water,
just living in a dust bowl essentially.
Um,
get some towers up for security.
And then it was pretty much it.
And there's how many of you out in this remote location?
We ended up having two sites.
And so we had mutually supporting positions within our team.
And I think we had probably 60 Americans.
So we had our 20 guys.
And then we actually had a trailer,
platoon of army infantry guys out there as well.
And so they would help provide security in San Posts and allow us to go out and
do missions.
So now you get into doing missions and what does that look like?
You're going out,
you,
you have to take people,
you have to move people,
you have to go and meet people.
Like what was the kind of standard,
um,
when you,
when you say mission to execute from those little forward operating basis,
what was kind of the standard mission that you would execute?
Cute.
Yeah.
So the mission is varied,
but for the most part,
uh,
and I was only there for about two months before I had gotten injured in,
came back.
But,
um,
the team we took over for had done a really good job and they had some very
challenging human dynamics within the EO.
Um,
they're gonna attacked multiple times a day.
So,
uh,
when we got there,
we tried to do whatever we could to,
to proactively prevent that from happening.
And so the standard practice that we would do is,
uh,
we'd go outside of those patrols,
try to find guys who were coming to kill us and kill them before they got us.
So,
uh,
to do that is not an insignificant task,
especially when you're going through a minefield.
Uh,
and so the TTPs that we kind of use at that time was we would go into the cover
of darkness,
uh,
which will allow us time to slowly and methodically get to where we wanted to
go,
uh,
take over a compound or a building,
um,
and then just stay there all day and observe and see what happened.
And then that next night,
usually exfil under the cover of darkness again.
And the Maine Mainers we did that was because a lot of the ideas that were out
and uh,
set up,
we're in positions
where they're just so many of them and they're in positions that were
advantageous and it would be observed by the enemy.
And so if
an entire compound had a few different ads in it,
and we started to realize that,
hey,
we,
we can't go on these compounds or we can't go near them because if there's
nobody in it,
most of the time they have [inaudible] the enemy would then wait until we were
in a position and just fire a few shots at us trying to drive us into those
positions and things.
And so just in general,
we just prefer to operate at night because,
uh,
they didn't have night vision capabilities that weren't able to shoot at us at
night.
And we were able to take our time and move very slowly and methodically through
the IED threat that we encountered.
And so that's how we were able to try to mitigate that.
Um,
and that was,
you know,
how we would usually conduct those missions and then
there,
how often would you actually get contact and once you are out set up in an
ambush possession,
I think almost almost a hundred percent of the time it felt like that at least.
Um,
and so we wouldn't go out everyday.
Uh,
so we'd stagger the Edis and obviously with the operational,
you know,
the number of people that we had.
Um,
we're trying to maximize the bang for our buck and,
and to be very efficient with that while also running other operations and
trying to build the police force and other types of,
you know,
upward lines of operation.
Um,
and so we'd go probably every few days.
So this is a very aggressive VSO.
Meshan yeah,
I mean this is more aggressive than I was thinking.
The term that was thrown around by some of the guys was smash mouth VSO.
Uh,
and so,
Oh,
if you look at the entire landscape of Afghanistan from the highest levels of
command and everything,
there were,
you know,
green,
yellow and red areas.
And if you look at that based on enemy activity or friendliness to coalition
forces,
the traditional model for VSO was,
hey,
put them in yellow areas that,
you know,
we're likely to be successful.
We can make some progress,
not in red areas,
right,
where people will just fight to the death and you know,
there's no chance of this happening.
And so,
uh,
different people have different thoughts of what's green,
yellow and red.
And so,
uh,
when we ended up there and that was our mission and we tried to make the most of
it.
So,
but yeah,
very different.
And so that,
and we even had teams,
other marines were out in the west and Herat province,
uh,
which was very different than the Helmand province.
And so out in Herat province,
guys are,
you know,
walking around with just a pistol and driving on motorbikes and,
drinking tea and hanging out,
no helmets,
like,
you know,
not getting shot at very,
very,
very different experience than,
than where we were.
Um,
and that,
that was great cause,
you know,
we're just glad different places of,
different portions of the country.
We were successful with that mission set.
And I think to a large degree,
most of the,
the special operations that conduct that mission,
we're very successful.
Um,
and for us,
you know,
it's debatable how successful we were,
but that was a very different environment.
Yeah.
I know there were guys that were going over to do it and they would ask me
about,
you know,
of what do you think of this and we're going to do this village civility thing.
And I was like,
Oh,
you're going to go out into the middle of,
you know,
Indian country with your platoon.
That's going to be an awesome mission.
Like it's going to be great.
Go get some,
go do a do good job.
I mean that's just a,
it's a cool mission.
It's just to be out there on your own.
I mean,
how much oversight did you have out there?
Not much.
I mean,
and that was,
that was one of the coolest things was having the freedom to go and execute.
And so,
you know,
whether or not it was destined for success based on what the situation was,
we were going to do the best we could to,
to make it success.
And we had a lot of resources to do that.
Whether it was,
you know,
the intelligence assets that we had at our disposal,
uh,
you know,
as a captain in the Marine Corps had assets that were like more than a new
commander.
Right.
Uh,
and same thing for casts and air support.
Um,
Roe was a bit restrictive for conventional forces and for us,
you know,
we were able to,
as long as we met certain criteria and,
and you know,
able to justify it,
we're able to drop cast where we needed to.
Um,
you know,
which was very different.
And so we did the best we could and made the most of it.
And then you're a couple months into deployment and that's when you got,
that's when you got wounded.
Yeah.
And what,
what happened on that op?
Yeah,
so we're starting to have some successes with the security bubble that we were
establishing.
And so,
uh,
we pushed a little bit further from our base to try to see where we thought
there would be any activity.
And so we went about,
I think maybe a click and a half on foot from her base and found ourselves in
Indian country essentially.
So we occupied a compound a on the cover of darkness.
And shortly after the sun rose immediately started seeing heavy activity around
us and started getting engaged from a multiple directions with,
with different weapons systems.
And so,
uh,
shortly after that happened,
there were three marines in,
on the rooftop of the compound that we're in.
Uh,
we have the rest of marines down,
surrounded,
protective,
or excuse me,
protected by the rest of the compound walls.
So most of the construction in Afghanistan is mud,
mud huts.
Um,
and despite not having running water or electricity or anything,
they were able to build these massive fortifications around each house.
And so the walls would protect you,
but you can't see anything.
So you also don't have situational awareness on what's going on.
And so as a commander,
as a leader of the patrol,
uh,
swapped out with Brian Jacqueline,
who was on the rooftop at that time to try to get awareness and so started
observing different things going on.
And,
and you know,
as I was up there,
an enemy fighter head,
uh,
engage us from our flank.
And so myself and another marine on the rooftop were shot.
A third marine was able to roll off without getting shot.
And so immediately a bullet went into my shoulder and into my spine.
And so I just felt a pulsing sensation in my back and kind of slumped over.
Saw Ricky,
who was the sergeant to my left.
He had been shot through the neck and was facedown on the rooftop.
Uh,
try to triage myself,
pick myself up and realize that nothing below my chest was working.
And so I immediately got on the radio,
called me,
guys,
told him that I'd been hit and that Rick had been hit and,
uh,
they sprung into action.
And so took the initiative to return fire,
gain,
fire superiority and tree.
How Jocelyn and continue to fight.
And how long did that last?
It was a long time.
I mean,
you're out there in the middle of nowhere and you're in a really hostile
situation.
How long did it take to get assets there?
Assets were pretty timely.
Um,
but it was also a very chaotic situation.
So at that time we had 10 Americans out on the mission.
Uh,
we had 10 of our Afghan partner force with us.
and so now we're down to eight Americans to are critically wounded.
We'd pull guns off the line as well to treat us,
saw our medic,
immediately started treating Ricky and I,
another marine,
start treating me as well as at least six.
Uh,
Brian Jacqueline immediately got on the radio and started to try to,
uh,
call in for Medivac and air support.
Um,
at that same moment,
Murphy's law kicked in as well,
and the Satcom antenna came down and source that coming pen and came down.
So we're now,
Brian was relaying through our main position all the information that was going
on.
And so,
uh,
getting pretty chaotic,
um,
and took about I think 30 minutes or so before the,
uh,
Medivac helicopters are able to come in and get us out.
And,
and,
and how bad was that?
What was the other guy's name that was hit Rick.
Ricky.
Yeah.
So he got shot in the neck.
Like what,
what was that all about?
Yeah,
and he was dead.
Yeah.
And,
um,
it turns out he
was very,
very,
very lucky.
So missed everything important in his neck,
missed his windpipe.
Mr Spine.
Uh,
he was unconscious for a while and we were both off the rooftop and,
uh,
our medic,
started working on him,
trying to bring him back to life while another marine was trying to keep me
stable.
And so,
uh,
put some click a lot and different clotting agents in his neck.
And all of a sudden Rick kind of woke up and made like a Zombie and it was like,
ah,
he was like blinking and stuff.
And so it turned out fine.
And Luckily today he's,
you know,
he's left the service,
but he just,
he's about to graduate from college.
He's in a bodybuilding and you know,
he's doing great,
which is awesome.
And so at that time he was pretty stable.
And,
uh,
I started to take a little bit of a turn for the worst because the bullet went
in my shoulder.
It also kind of punctured one of my lungs and sent her to have blood pooling in
my,
uh,
the left side of my chest cavity.
And so,
uh,
guys were trying to get us out of there.
So he was conscious.
I was,
yeah,
for the most part until towards,
towards the end where I started to,
to fade a little bit.
And then did you,
did you eventually just,
did you pass out,
they hit you with morphine?
Would they,
would they do,
I didn't get any drugs until,
I don't think I got to get drugs until I got on the helicopter.
And then,
uh,
while I was on the helicopter passed out and woke up in a hospital in
Afghanistan.
But I do remember the event.
And so I remember making the radio call to my teammates swallows on the rooftop,
remember getting pulled down,
remember talking to a huffys.
Uh,
one of the Marines who was working on me,
uh,
talking him through a Needle d,
as he was giving me a needle,
trying to tell him and talked to him and stuff.
And he said,
uh,
you know,
he said some side,
it said some interesting things while I was there too.
And uh,
you know,
so just to give people a little bit of a visual on that,
a needle decompression is when you're,
when somebody is going to take a what,
like a 14 gauge needle or something like that and jam it in between your ribs
into your lung cavity to allow some pressure out.
And you had to talk him through that.
He knew what he was doing,
but I was just,
you know,
just trying to encourage them in different things.
And so at that time it was also trying to relay information to help them find
the bad guys.
And it was fine who they were trying to,
uh,
return fire for or against.
And so,
uh,
it was talking to him on try to talk them on initially and then after that it
was just trying to talk to them to make sure,
make you know,
and then the helicopters and sat down in your compound.
No,
they couldn't.
So that was a big challenge.
And so,
uh,
what happened and what Brian Jacqueline was awarded the Navy Cross for a and a
lot of other guys who all risk their lives to save ours did was they had to call
him the helicopters out into an open field,
uh,
despite being under fire.
And so they prepped the area with as much air support as they could call it in
the bird.
And the bird landed.
Uh,
Brian blew a breach in the compound wall through smoke.
And then literally what he said was,
if you get hit on the way to the chopper,
jump in,
follow me.
And led the way.
And without hesitation,
the other guys carried this out to the open and not a small guy.
You know what,
I'm 200 pounds of barrel chested freedom fighter,
just like most of us with an,
you know,
a lot of lot of kid on too.
And so,
uh,
those guys carrying us out there,
we're in a a polis and so to carry us,
it takes four guys and they can't return fire.
They can't pick up their weapon and engage the enemy.
So they're totally exposed and without hesitation,
ran out there and doing the bullet dance dodging bullets,
trying to get us on the bird and get us out of there.
And I'm alive today because of that.
And so that for me,
what I tell people when I talk about this is,
is one of the best days of my life.
And so I was one of the worst days of my life to cause I suffered a spinal cord
injury and was paralyzed from the chest down for however long that may be.
But I was one of the best days of my life because a team that I was fortunate
enough to lead a team that I was fortunate enough to be a part of display.
The highest levels of,
of selflessness and sacrifice and courage on the battlefield.
Uh,
and just to witness that and to be a part of that,
you know,
is something I'll never forget and it's up and I'll be proud of for the rest of
my life.
So,
uh,
yeah.
And if in case anyone missed it,
the opening for this was actually,
um,
those are,
those are a gunnery sergeant Jacqueline's words that he,
that he gave during a speech and I thought they were just so,
uh,
they were just awesome words,
so I figured I'd share them with some people and obviously the rest of the guys,
you know,
a bunch of kick ass guys that like you said,
I mean,
just incredible heroism across the board from your,
from your team,
you now and,
and by the way,
and actually,
and Jacqueline,
I mentioned this in the speech as well.
Um,
there was some,
there was some seals like you said that I guess it was the guys that were under
their guys from seal team three that came in.
And,
um,
I actually talked to one of those guys today because,
uh,
I knew,
you know,
because you were coming on and I just a it was,
um,
I talked to him was Dan Crenshaw and,
and I just told him,
I said,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm talking to Derek today.
And he's like,
oh,
that's awesome.
And it was just cool.
It was just cool to hear the praise coming from Jacqueline.
And that's exactly the same thing that the Dan Crenshaw said.
He's like,
yeah,
those guys were awesome.
I mean,
that's just,
that's as he,
you know,
I said,
I know you were on that mission,
right?
And he goes,
he goes,
oh yeah.
He goes,
those guys were awesome.
That,
that's what he said.
And it was cool to hear Jacqueline saying the same thing.
And you know,
a lot of times people get,
I guess people get caught up in whatever it is interservice rivalry.
And I actually literally have zero of that.
I,
especially after my deployment to Ramadi,
I have zero interservice rivalry of any kind.
Like,
if you're on the battlefield and you have an American flag on your uniform,
you are my brother.
And it was awesome to hear that feedback from both those guys.
Um,
you,
he wake up in the hospital and you're an affricate year and a hospital in
Afghanistan.
Yup.
Yeah.
I wake up in camp bastion,
uh,
doctors there and a,
he's like a captain.
Uh,
you got shot and you may,
you know,
you're paralyzed and you may never walk again.
And I just kind of stare at them and say,
yeah,
I know I'm Kinda had this awkward stare off.
And I'm like,
hey,
it'd be telling my wife yet.
He's like,
no,
he's got stares at me.
I'm like,
go get me a goddamn phone.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Got It.
And so,
uh,
brings over the phone and I wake my wife up in the middle of the night,
you know?
So you knew immediately I knew.
Yeah,
I knew that that was the case.
Uh,
literally the second I got shot,
you know,
cause I tried to pick myself up and it's hard to understand if you,
you who've never experienced it,
but you know,
if just your body is numb and nothing works then you know,
you know,
and so like totally knew that that was the case and uh,
didn't know how long it would last,
but I knew that that was what the issue was.
And so,
um,
called my wife and woke her up,
told her,
you know,
hey,
I've been shot paralyzing,
may never walk again and I'm coming home.
And so that was pretty tough time and you know,
brief on tough phone call to make,
but through it all,
we're just really happy that I was able to make that phone call,
you know,
cause a lot of guys don't get to do that.
And so then moved on.
Um,
getting back to Germany,
spent a couple of days there.
They didn't do anything,
uh,
for my condition.
Just kind of waited,
transport back to Bethesda,
uh,
where I checked in and,
and,
uh,
met my wife and family and they started to do some other surgeries to remove the
bullet from my spine and some other,
uh,
other things.
And so our guys at that time too were they,
uh,
they stayed put in the compound and fought for the rest of the day.
Uh,
rebelled,
a few different enemy assaults.
And then as you mentioned,
the seal team that had come in to be the quick reactionary force for them,
uh,
came in at night and Jacqueline did the turnover with them.
They came in to kind of reinforce the area and do some,
some battle damage assessment.
Uh,
and then that's when Dan had gotten injured.
And so,
um,
so the guys had gotten out and you know,
the rest of our guys made it out of that day without,
without any further injuries.
Uh,
and so was in Bethesda and started my recovery process there with my wife by my
side.
And moving forward.
And that recovery process is,
uh,
I heard you saying one of your other videos that you have out there,
you're just talking about the new normal,
like,
okay,
this is the new normal.
This is what it is and I'm going forward.
Yeah.
And,
um,
the doctors were pretty noncommittal.
So when I was there,
they didn't say,
you'll never walk again.
And they didn't say,
you know,
what are you can or can't do?
They said,
you know,
hey,
you have a spinal cord injury.
It's very severe.
It's very,
you know,
it's a big deal,
but if you recover function,
you know,
the research shows that it might happen in the first two years,
most likely.
And so that was good.
Uh,
in some ways and bad in other ways it was good because it left me,
uh,
the opportunity to change,
you know,
to,
to control my mindset in,
to say,
hey,
like,
so what?
I'm going to get up in in six weeks and go run a marathon or,
or whatever.
Um,
the challenge with that though was that was a little bit,
that was good for me to get through those initial stages,
but it was also naive of me to not let the reality sink in.
And so,
you know,
when that didn't happen in six weeks and I didn't walk and I wasn't gaining
control or function of anything below my chest,
uh,
that's when it started to get real.
And like,
it was really challenging for me to deal with,
uh,
because I didn't,
you know,
it was out of my control,
the level of,
you know,
the permanence of my injury.
And then what,
what,
was there anything that helped you get through that transition of when you,
all of a sudden six weeks goes by and at you,
you,
the reality starts to hit you that made you say,
okay,
here's what I'm going to do.
Yeah.
It was,
it was bad for about,
I think,
probably first four to six months.
Um,
and the reason why,
the reason why,
it's probably the lowest point actually,
definitely the lowest point was,
uh,
August 10th of 2012 so about two months after I got injured,
I had transferred to a Va facility in Tampa,
Florida.
Uh,
cause that was a major spinal cord injury clinic.
And so the military dod side doesn't have spinal cord injury recovery.
They have it all in the Va.
So it was just me and the VA with my wife.
We relocated there.
And on that day,
actually,
that was the day that uh,
three other marines in our company from a different team were killed in an
insider attack in Sangin.
Uh,
and so Captain Matthew Manoukian,
Gunnery Sergeant Ryan,
Jesse and Staff Sergeant Scott Mode,
we're all three guys that weren't in my team,
but there were friends of mine that were killed and we're coming home.
And so it was hard to deal with that.
It was hard cause I was still in the hospital,
I couldn't go to any of the funerals.
And then it was continued to be hard after that because,
uh,
it just reinforced the fact that my guys are out there vulnerable and I wasn't
there to lead them and that was my job and I felt like it was failing them every
day,
you know?
And so all of my wife was there with me throughout this recovery process as
lonely,
you know,
everything you do in the militaries and teams,
you're always from day one boot camp,
you have a buddy for everything.
And now this was the first time in the military when I'm,
I'm alone.
And uh,
you know,
without any control over the outcome of what would happen to my guys.
And so
that was tough.
That was like definitely,
definitely the toughest part of the recovery process.
And so luckily I was able to fly back to California and see them touch down in
December.
All the guys made it back safe and sound.
And then that was really what I was able to start to put the pieces back
together and go forward and move on with my life.
What did that look like?
Picking up the pieces and putting them back together.
And the reason I'm asking this
is just because,
you know,
I'm looking at where you're at right now and if there's any buddy that could be
listening that could say,
okay,
let me hear what he did so I can emulate that.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the key things.
There's,
there's a couple things that I did that I think are,
um,
very similar to some of the stuff that you've,
you've talked about before and one is mission and purpose.
And so recovering in the hospital,
sitting there by herself wasn't the mission that,
that I signed up for.
And so as soon as I possibly could,
I was back at work.
And so I was back in the ops section in January,
you know,
as a future operations officer trying to do powerpoints and slides and all the
other stuff that,
you know,
that officers are our tasks to do.
And it was great cause nobody else wanted to do that,
that stuff.
So I was happy to take it on and do it.
Um,
and so being around the team,
providing something meaningful for them and,
uh,
having an impact was more important for my psyche than anything else.
Um,
other two things I've kind of looked at were like very stoic philosophy,
stoic mindset,
and realizing that,
you know,
somethings are out of my control,
but I do have control over the way I choose to react to things,
the way I choose to move forward with my life and that I have opportunities,
opportunities that guys like Matt Ryan and sky don't have.
And so for me to squander that,
for me not to take advantage of every day and move forward in a way that they
would be proud of is a complete waste.
And so that makes it really easy to stop feeling sorry for yourself and to keep
pushing and to keep doing whatever you want to do.
And so those were the two things.
I think that every day,
even to this day,
continue to push me forward is like,
you know,
uh,
setting out on the mission and the vision that I want to achieve and the purpose
for my life and taken advantage of every day because,
you know,
it's an opportunity.
I have something that,
that every day I wake up,
I can go and create or do or,
or build or make something meaningful and to not take advantage of that as is
to,
to squander an opportunity that,
that anyone of those guys would love to have.
So it makes it real simple and easy for me to do.
Oh man,
brother.
Um,
yeah.
That's awesome man.
That's,
that's awesome.
As an awesome attitude.
How long did you stay,
how long did you keep working in,
in the Marine Corp for
sit for about another two years after that.
So Marine Corps is pretty cool.
They have some programs in place for guys who were injured in the line of duty
where you can stay in essentially as long as you want,
as long as you keep getting promoted and keep contributing.
And so for me,
I didn't pursue those longer term programs,
um,
because I started to find some other opportunities that was,
was as passionate about and wanted to pursue outside the military.
And so I continued to work for about two as a staff officer,
um,
working with first,
you know,
the operations section as we were transitioning and trying to assign to mission
sets and supporting all those different types of operation,
uh,
operational planning efforts.
And,
uh,
I'd gone back to business school part time to try to learn about business and to
go get more education.
Um,
and then I became really passionate about a new opportunity and medical
technology and medical research and thought that that was where my next big
impact would be.
And so decided to officially retire from the military in November of 2014 and
have been out since then.
And what was the,
uh,
what was the new opportunity and,
and where did that lead?
So the opportunity that arose was to start a company and try to address issues
and unmet needs,
socio spinal cord injury.
And so I learned firsthand how many challenges and how many issues there are in
addition to just being in a wheelchair that a lot of people don't see.
And so everything from bowels,
bladder management,
sexual function,
physical training,
osteopenic,
bone density and muscle mass,
there's so many different things that are challenges that are unmet needs of the
people like me and the patient population of which I'm a part of.
And so the idea and the company that we started is called spinal singularity,
and that's what we're working to solve.
And so our first product,
the first thing we're working on,
which is in clinical studies now,
is a,
a smart catheter for bladder management.
And so it allows people to push a button and empty their bladder,
uh,
which is currently,
you know,
much more advanced and much more useful and functional than the current method
of management.
And so that's what we've been working on for the past past few years.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
um,
as I was kind of reading about the stuff that you've been working on,
and,
and even on that,
uh,
item right there,
he reminded me of when,
uh,
when my buddy Jody Mitic came down to be on the podcast and he's,
you know,
he's a double amputee and,
but,
you know,
I would see pictures of him walking around and he would do,
like,
he did some big race up in Canada.
I forget what the race was called,
the amazing race.
And he would do all this like really badass stuff that I would think,
hey,
you know,
it's,
it's all good.
And,
and um,
when he came down here,
um,
I think it might've been the second time he came down here.
So there was a second time he came down here and we like hung out more because,
you know,
he came down for a little bit more time and we were a little bit tighter.
But,
um,
he,
well first of all,
I got him a hotel room and he called me and he said,
hey,
I'm not going to stay at that hotel because a,
they don't have a handicap stuff there.
And I was like,
kind of,
I was like,
okay,
yeah man,
cool.
You know,
whatever.
But in my mind,
I was kinda thinking to myself like,
why,
why does he need that?
Because I see him walking around and he's running the damn amazing race.
Right.
And then,
so I asked him,
I was like,
Whoa,
you know,
like later I didn't ask them on the phone.
I said,
yeah,
the cool whatever you want.
And then later I talked to him,
I was like,
why do you,
why do you need that?
I wasn't trying to be a jerk,
I was just honestly asking.
And he was like,
yeah,
well,
you know,
like at night,
I mean,
I,
I take my legs off and I got to crawl around and if I got to pull myself up on
the toilet,
I got to pull myself in the shower and like,
if there's not handles and stuff,
uh,
you know,
it sucks.
And so that was like part one of this story.
Part two was we,
he wanted to walk around San Diego,
um,
you know,
see what I lived and go to the ocean and all this kind of stuff.
And so we did that and we had gone to the mid way aircraft carrier and walked
around there and then we walked downtown and we walked.
We were,
then we went to where I live and we were kind of like walking in the beach area
and I could see he was kind of like slowing down.
I could see his face getting a little bit,
you know,
like,
like a little bit of a,
a little bit of strain in his face.
And he's like,
Hey man,
let me sit down for a minute.
And then he,
he'd sit down and we talk a little bit,
then he'd say,
okay,
let's go.
And then he'd say,
look,
lay,
let's sit down and findings that came in.
Can we just go back to your house?
Like,
my legs are really hurting.
And you know,
like,
yeah,
guess what?
You're,
you're putting all that pressure on,
on their stumps and,
and it wears away the skin and it's,
it's,
you know,
it's hard and it sucks.
And um,
I guess,
so that's part number two.
And what these two things reinforced to me is,
you know what,
like,
there's so much going on that week that I don't see that that did,
cause,
you know,
I hadn't been injured like that.
There's so many things going on.
They don't like all,
you know,
he's doing okay.
It's like,
yeah,
he's doing okay.
You're seeing him for like two hours,
three hours.
He's living like that 24 hours a day.
And he's got all these things to contend with that haven't even remotely crossed
my mind.
And so when I,
when I saw the,
yeah,
I mean straight up the first time I ever it ever entered my mind,
how you take a Piss,
how you would take a piss and the first time it ever entered my mind when I was
researching what your medical devices are.
And I was like,
you know,
how,
how ignorant m I,
you know,
to be sitting here in net,
never even thought of that.
And then that's one of all these other problems that you have to contend with on
a daily basis.
And it's,
uh,
you know,
it's a daily,
it's a daily struggle.
And you know,
something,
something Jim Webb brought up as well.
Um,
he,
he was talking about different types of courage and he brought up something
called daily courage and he's talked about one of his friends that was wounded
and he's like,
every day it takes him 20 minutes to get out of bed.
It takes him 15 minutes to get here and you know,
to the other side of his room,
he's like,
that's daily courage that he has to show.
And I'm thinking to myself,
Yelp,
and you know,
it just makes me feel like there's so much,
there's so much more that you know,
you through on a daily basis that we and me,
I completely take for granted a completely take it for granted.
And so for me to sit here and talk to you and,
and realize we know how hard it is for you on a daily basis,
the things you have to go through and then to hear you say like,
yeah,
but I'm glad I'm here on like my brothers who didn't come home.
Yeah.
I don't think anyone has any excuses,
really none.
So,
um,
yeah,
totally agree.
And uh,
just makes you that much more
creative with your mindset,
right?
Like you look at all the challenges but also look at the opportunities,
So I can sprint through airports much faster than you can with that.
I can't even stress,
I got good parking most of the time,
you know,
so he's got to make up time where you can write.
It takes me a little bit longer to get off the airplane but kill you on the
straightaways any day.
And so,
uh,
you know,
you just got to take,
take the go to the bed,
but you know,
it's,
it's not a choice.
So that was the,
that was the,
you got your MBA
add as is that while you were still in,
you went and got your Mba or did you get out?
I got out about halfway through,
so I did a part time program at Ucla.
It's an executive Mba,
so it's on the weekends every other weekend.
And so as I was leaving the military,
so I did the first year I was still a full on active duty and then retired
shortly at in the second year,
uh,
took another job at another medical device,
start up to get some experience.
And then as soon as I graduated,
started full time,
uh,
working on spinal singularity in my company.
And so,
um,
one of the experiences too that was really cool that,
uh,
I had as part of their retirement,
I think about it now,
was,
uh,
being able to use and be involved in as a user exoskeleton technology.
And so there's robotic exoskeleton technology that allows parallel paraplegics
to stand and walk.
So,
um,
because of a lot of generous donors and the Brain Raider Foundation,
uh,
I was able to be,
to use that device into,
to obtain that device even before FDA approval.
And so I had a really,
really a great set up within our,
our battalion headquarters and our office.
And so we had a physical therapist downstairs.
My office was upstairs.
I was fully accessible,
which is not like most buildings in the military.
Um,
and so I was able to use this device to stand and walk and to do therapy.
And,
uh,
when I retired I was able to use that device and not use my wheelchair to all to
leave on my own two feet,
which was a goal that I'd set for myself.
And so that was great.
Um,
but it still didn't address a lot of these other unmet needs that we had for the
community.
And so that was what inspired me to try to move forward on my own path and start
my own company and build this product to,
to solve these issues.
So,
um,
so yeah,
so very thankful for all the donors and the,
the,
the foundation to help support that.
Um,
and I was also very fortunate,
so like you said,
a lot of other people had gone before me.
And so one of my classmates at the Naval Academy,
a guy named Matt Lampert,
uh,
got to First Marine Raider Battalion about two years before I did because he was
on the quick cycle of deployments.
And in 2010,
he was a bilateral amputee above the knee as I was going through the training
pipeline.
And so I went up and saw him in,
in a Bethesda hospital and just checked in with them real briefly as a,
as he was coming back and I'm starting his rehab.
And you know,
this is maybe a week after he'd gotten off the battlefield or less.
And he says,
you know,
like,
so what are you going to do?
And he's like,
I'm gonna go back,
like go back to California.
He's like,
no,
I'm going back to Afghanistan.
Like,
okay,
Gotcha.
And I'm thinking like,
man,
Dallas,
how's he going to do that?
And sure enough,
as I graduated from training,
he was my company executive officer.
They checked me in and then we deployed again.
So when I had gotten injured and deployed,
he was there as their company X.
So,
um,
and then after my friend Matt had gotten killed,
he went down and took over his team as a bilateral amputee above the knees.
And so,
you know,
he had come back,
he had done that.
He had tried that path.
And so for me,
you know,
going back and recovering,
uh,
our building was accessible,
you know,
it's wheelchair accessible.
There was a lot of other things.
And then just that example that he said as well was,
uh,
was really helpful and inspiring for me to follow.
And so,
um,
so yeah,
so really,
really fortunate in the Rehab Environment,
especially because of all the assets that SOCOM has.
And so if I had been in the ground's been a totally,
totally different story for how the recovery would have gone.
Um,
you know,
my entire command was super supportive of,
of me coming back and working and doing,
I said,
whatever you need,
whatever you want,
you want to go to ops,
like,
sure,
let's do it giddy up.
And so,
uh,
yeah.
So it was a good place to recover.
When you hear about like when you say broadly,
like if I was a grunt,
I would've gotten that kind of support.
I mean,
I get that because,
you know,
in the seal teams we have the same thing.
Like,
like people will rally around and make stuff happen.
Um,
is there any organizations that you know of that sort of support,
like the,
the front line soldier marine that gets,
that gets a catastrophic?
We wounded?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
there's a lot of different nonprofits out there.
Semper fi fund is a big one.
Um,
there's a lot of different groups of support them and,
and,
and it's different.
It's not that they don't have the assets,
um,
it's just the location of those assets.
And so an infantry battalion has a very different operational mission and leeway
than a special operations battalion.
Um,
and so for all of the guys that were injured in the conventional forces,
when they come back,
they're immediately sent to wounded warrior battalion at the hospital.
And so their job is now show up to your appointments,
into your rehab until you get separated from the military.
Yeah.
Um,
that's a very different way to recover with a bunch of other people who are
injured or on their way out or whatever else versus,
you know,
and,
and without an operational purpose,
then what I was able to do,
and I was very fortunate to do where I went back to an operational goal with an
Italian and I was the only one of the only injured guys,
you know,
recovering around normal people because I wanted to be like that.
Yeah.
I don't know if you ever know a guy named Jake Schick,
but he was on here and he told his story and that's like,
that's what it was.
He was there.
He was like,
his job was just to kind of recover,
but you could see and talking to him,
he,
he would have loved to have had some kind of a higher purpose than just that,
which eventually he made.
He made it for himself.
He made his own organization to help wounded vets and,
and,
uh,
help suicide prevention with 22 kill.
Um,
but yeah,
so I think that that's a,
that's a good comparison,
you know,
just from hearing him tell his story about,
what his recovery was.
I can,
it was,
it was geared towards,
okay,
you're going to do this until you get out of the Marine Corps.
I guarantee,
you know,
you've talked to Jake Schick for three minutes and you're gonna realize if,
if you could have told him,
hey,
we want you to do this for the Marine Corps,
he would have been all over it.
He would have gone and done anything.
You know,
cause he's a bad ass.
Uh,
but,
but yeah,
no,
that's a,
that's a good point.
And that's,
well you've heard me say it cause you kind of referenced it a little bit.
You know,
I always tell guys that need to find a new mission,
whatever that new mission is,
you got to find a new mission.
You can't be sitting around with no mission man.
You've had a mission for,
for,
for whatever,
eight years,
seven years,
20 years,
however long it's been.
You had,
you had a mission,
you had a goal and if that goes away,
you,
you got to find a new one.
And it doesn't really matter what it is.
I mean pick something good.
Right?
I mean your mission shouldn't be,
it shouldn't involve whiskey,
but pick something positive and something good.
Move in the right direction.
How is,
how is s a spinal singularity doing right now?
Like what's the,
what's the status we're doing really well?
So,
uh,
it's been a good three years.
Um,
I learned a ton and just the fact that we're still in business today is,
it was pretty amazing because I had zero experience,
right?
I had no clue what I was doing cause I,
no experience in the medical device industry had no network.
Um,
and so the first year it was a lot of,
lot of faith,
a lot of ups and downs,
right.
And,
uh,
just like starting any business,
but especially in the medical device industry,
uh,
I learned a ton and then was fortunate enough to find people to bring in that
are experienced and then a trust.
And so,
um,
we've raised money from investors.
We've raised money from grants and non dilutive sources.
Um,
and we're retina and we have a small team of six employees in,
in San Clemente.
And,
uh,
we're running a large clinical study across the u s right now.
And so we have sites all over everywhere from Minnesota,
New Jersey to,
you know,
uh,
all over in California and Arizona were,
those
sites are actively enrolling people interested in,
in supporting our trial.
And so how long has that trial need to last before it gets approval?
Uh,
so the goal is to have approval,
um,
internationally next year and then hopefully by the end of the year,
uh,
we can have FDA approval for the product as well.
Uh,
we're in 100% certain that does happen,
but that's uh,
that's the goal and hopefully we can collect the data we need as quickly as
possible to,
to accomplish that.
And then do you have your next device in mind after this one?
One goes live.
Got Ideas.
Regret.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I'm always,
I've always been like a versatile guy,
not like the execution,
like the a hundred percent of the zero to 90% guy,
not the 90 to 100% and bring it home.
Got It.
And so I know that's how everybody else that we were,
you know,
everybody else in our team now or like the 90 to 100% guys.
And so,
um,
I'm trying to be more like that,
but not even think about it.
Cause if,
if this doesn't work,
got it.
You know,
there is no business,
right?
Like,
we've put all of our,
you know,
this is what we raise money to do.
You know,
we haven't,
we don't,
we can't knowingly devote a minute of time to anything else until this is
successful.
So you'll get hit with that,
then we can kind of go back to the drawing board.
Thanks sense.
But,
and once it's approved here,
then it just,
then it's just a sailing it,
selling it and getting it out there and it's going into the,
into the world.
And then what about the,
uh,
what about the Marine Raider Foundation,
which is another thing you were involved with?
Yeah.
So,
um,
after I was injured,
I was very ignorant.
The realities of the way things work and what the needs would be a for me.
And so,
um,
a lot of nonprofits out there do all kinds of great work and different things.
As a Marine Raider,
uh,
in this situation,
without knowing anything,
you know,
I didn't want to talk to anybody that I was very hesitant to reach out for help
to anybody.
Um,
and so as these things arose,
you know,
one of the guys who is,
or was,
is it employee of the organization now and then,
so it wasn't currently an active duty rate or at that time it was like,
hey man,
like we're starting this nonprofit to help guys.
Like if you need anything,
just say,
say so.
And so I was like,
all right,
cool.
Um,
and so they helped pay for my wife to move out to Tampa so she can be there for
my recovery,
helped,
uh,
you know,
get her car out there so she could drive around and help transport me around to
different things.
Um,
they helped us raise money for the exoskeleton cause it was still not covered by
insurance or the Va.
It was still experimental at that time.
Um,
and helps do all of these things.
And so,
you know,
my wife and I are eternally grateful for all the support we received from them.
And so as soon as I got out of the military,
uh,
that organization said,
Hey,
do you want to be a board member?
Do you want to help?
And I'm like,
yes,
absolutely.
And so that was 2014 and so I've been on the board since then and I think it was
2015 I took over as the board president.
And so I've been trying to devote my spare time to help that organization,
but the missions that we serve and ultimately,
uh,
what we do at the foundation is just to support unmet needs of the community and
their families.
And so the government's really good at supporting injured veterans and,
and they have so many different programs that,
that help people.
But,
uh,
every situation is unique.
And so,
um,
Congress isn't going to change a law to appropriate money for you to not do
something that doesn't fall into the black and white letter of the law.
And that's fine.
Um,
but that's where we step in and are able to help things to help people and,
uh,
you know,
take the stress off of them in their times of need.
So at four real major areas,
one is support to the,
the marine Raiders,
uh,
and others,
family resiliency.
Third one is tragedy assistance and survivor support.
And then the last one is a raider legacy and preservation.
And so,
um,
obviously the raider support and the family support are pretty broad,
uh,
ways to work.
And they can be anything from,
you know,
just anything under the sun that,
that will help marines and their families.
Um,
tragedy assistance or survivor support,
even though,
uh,
you know,
we're engaged in varying levels of combat.
There's still guys out there putting their lives on the line every day.
And that's evidenced by a recent training incident that we had about two years
ago.
Less than two years ago in 2017,
there was a c one 30 crash that claimed the lives of seven marine Raiders.
Um,
and then two years before that helicopter crash in,
uh,
another training mission out off the coast of Florida that took another lodge
and other seven guys.
And so,
um,
being able to support their,
their,
uh,
families and family members that had,
had survived those incidences is a,
a big part of the mission that we,
we fulfill.
And then read her legacy in preservation just
cause they want one thing.
When you hit on this a little bit,
but I'm just going to expand a little bit so people can kind of understand when
you talked about like congress isn't going to change a law to give a family that
what they needed a certain time cause it's too specific or whatever.
And the reality is,
let let's say a kid,
you know,
needs a new bicycle and there's,
there's,
you know,
the dad can't go and get it because he's wounded,
he's in the hospital.
Like that's the kind of things that the foundation could do.
Go Out,
buy the bike,
get it built and deliver.
You know,
like little things like that,
that really matter.
Um,
and it can be bigger things too.
Like you said,
like moving a family,
helping to pay for the movement of a family,
helping had read deck,
get furniture for the new apartment,
whatever it is.
There's no law that takes care of those situations.
But these types of organizations do that and it,
and it does have a big deal,
uh,
has a huge impact for those,
for those families that are there.
And believe me,
when those families are going the most tough situations,
these little things to be able to not have them think about it,
not have them think about,
hey,
the,
the cost of a flight to fly,
you know,
dad out to come and visit his song or whatever.
Any,
any of those little things,
they don't seem like a big deal.
But there are a huge deal when families are going through these traumatic times.
Yeah.
So another example,
uh,
when
my friend Matt was killed and his family went to go pick him up at Dover,
uh,
one of the last,
you know,
things that his mother wanted was her whole family to fly home with them.
And the government only pay for the father and mother,
I think it was.
And so,
uh,
the other two brothers and some other family friends,
they wanted to all be on the same flight.
And it was one thing that she wanted you to know and she didn't want anything
else.
Just said,
hey,
I want us all to be on the same plane going home while we're,
we're grieving with my son.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
so instead of having to deal with that and the insanity of it to you,
I'll just tell her,
hey,
we got your life where you're like,
you're on the plane.
You're good.
Perfect example.
Such a small,
seemingly small gesture,
but with a timely injection of support can have a really lifelong impact on,
on people.
And so,
um,
those are some of the,
the different experiences and I can go on and on about different ways that we've
been able to help people.
But bottom line is guys are going out and doing these different things and for
them to be able to go forward and,
and to,
to fight with a happy heart,
uh,
they want to know their families are taken care of on the back side and the
community will support them.
And so that's,
that's letter.
It is.
We just,
you know,
we're five,
one c three that raises money to support the community members in their time of
need.
And then the last one is legacy.
Yeah.
So,
which is legit because you guys,
I mean you guys kind of are saving the legacy of the original World War II
Raiders,
right?
Yes.
We're trying to,
and so,
um,
can you explain how that,
how you guys adopted the name?
Cause it's been nice.
It's awesome.
It's a good history.
So,
uh,
so the marine Raiders,
the World War II marine Raiders were one of the first special operations units
formed a period and they were formed in World War II and their mission was to
conduct enemy,
uh,
deeper connoisseur.
It's essentially,
um,
prior to invasions in the Pacific.
And so these guys would mount up and rubber boats.
They were the first ones to do submarine lockouts and uh,
you know,
and some of the things that they did were just insane even by today's standards.
Um,
and so these guys were very well trained,
uh,
and basically provided the lineage of,
of who we are,
who we are today.
And so those,
that group and then,
uh,
other members also joined the Oss,
at that time,
which was the precursor to the CIA.
Uh,
there was a lot of marines at that,
that unit as well.
And those are the two kind of,
uh,
units that we draw our lineage from as,
as the marine special operations units today.
And so these guys were disbanded in 1946 after they came back,
or maybe it was even 1945 after the war.
Um,
and so,
uh,
we've been very active in connecting with these guys.
They have an association,
uh,
that actually Colonel Kaczynski is,
is in charge of now.
He's the president of the Marine Raider Association,
which is a social organization,
not,
not an un,
no,
not as,
not a five,
one c three.
Um,
and so
one of these guys are still alive today,
a World War II veterans.
Um,
and so we get to go and meet with them and talk with them and hear these stories
of these amazing missions they did and,
and conducting a month long and patrols behind enemy lines,
um,
you know,
sabotaging the Japanese and,
and different,
uh,
different battles.
Um,
and so these guys were very,
very vocal and outspoken to different leadership within the Marine Corps as
they're all in their nineties and passing away.
And I said,
Hey,
one way to honor our legacy is to have a marine raider.
You don't have a Marine Raider unit today.
And that went over terribly with any leadership because if you don't know,
there's,
there's a pretty strong culture and brainwashing done within the Marine Corps
and it's from day one.
There's only one title that matters.
It's that you're a marine here,
it's one or a zero.
You're a marine,
you already elite.
No one has special or everyone,
everyone is special and no one is special.
You know,
you're all replaceable,
but you're all special.
Um,
which is the weirdest conundrum,
but all of us believe it.
And at the highest levels,
uh,
title of any unit you know,
that thinks you're special,
you know,
is against the entire culture.
And so since formation,
since the marine special operations command was officially formed in 2006 from
the force reconnaissance units,
overnight,
they became the marine special operations command.
So literally changed the guide.
On a,
at a ceremony and then they're officially socom assets.
Um,
there was this undercurrent,
this push from the lowest levels,
uh,
and guys were really strongly pushing this and saw the Raiders symbol.
The Raider logo from World War II was a,
you know,
a shield with the southern cross and a skull and a dagger in it.
Um,
and so are assuming the dagger sign there.
We have the dagger for some of our units now it's just the skull in the southern
cross.
Um,
and so guys would wear patches and patches are and other things that the Marine
Corps,
oh,
I know.
Beards.
Anything that is not in strict adherence with the uniform policy is not
tolerated.
And so,
you know,
that's a quick way to get,
get hammered.
Right.
It's just like,
you're not special.
What do you think you're doing?
This is an authorized,
all that kind of stuff.
Whereas the army is like,
you know,
the army about,
hey,
I'm in the seal teams.
We have our points for flare.
Right?
Yeah.
So you guys aren't adding back.
So embarrassing.
Expected to have like to look cool.
Right.
Um,
more than the Marine Corps.
It was this consistent undercurrent pushing and pushing and pushing until it's
patches.
And then it became tattoos.
So guys would get the Raider,
I'm blown just tattooed on their chest and then not wear skinny shirts.
So you just see,
so like,
you know,
you're going into your first sergeant and they're like,
where's your skinny shirt?
Devil done.
Let's give a shirt on you.
Excuse
me.
Um,
and so it wasn't official until he was about two years ago,
year and a half ago after a decade of insurgency from the units that,
uh,
that we have a name and I think it's directly attributed to a album rec.
Raven actually.
So within SOCOM,
um,
he's a really smart guy,
phenomenal commander obviously.
And uh,
he gets marketing and branding and just the basic,
you know,
title,
right?
Like you've earned the title of marine and within the special operations
community you are in the title of seal and Greenbrae.
And so he said,
hey,
my,
one of my last things I want to do,
like I want to work with the common on the Marine Corps.
I want you guys to get a title and yeah,
and it's,
it's not even about marketing and branding,
it's about heritage and unit pride.
I mean,
what,
what more awesome thing then to take and keep alive that tradition from World
War Two of those guys in the service and sacrifice that they had.
It's,
it's bad ass,
man.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
As part of that too,
you know,
there's just like everything growing up,
right?
Like we're growing up as an organization,
so we're new to SOCOM,
so we're,
we're trying to figure it out as quick as we can.
Uh,
so we'd have our military special occupational specialty code.
So that took a while til we had to stay in the Raiders now for their whole
career.
Yes.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
because initially when they started,
it wasn't the case,
right?
It was like,
well,
we'll let socom use you guys,
but then we want to use you to,
so every five years you're coming back to the fleet and you're going to be in an
infantry company or a rifle platoon and stuff.
And they were like,
guys,
when I first joined the navy,
I've talked about this before,
the Marines didn't have names on their uniforms because they didn't need them
because your name was lance corporal,
your name was staff sergeant.
And that's it.
It was legit.
I always had a lot of respect for that.
But of course now they have them.
But uh,
I always thought that that that shows you,
there's like less slow,
you know,
there's a slow change in the Marine Corps.
I'm sure some people would say that it's not good.
But,
uh,
yeah,
it just is,
it's just the Marine Corps be Green Weenie then
here it comes again.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's good.
And so,
so we haven't,
I'm less guys can stick around.
We have,
uh,
a name,
we have a badge now.
We have,
uh,
like a,
you know,
just like you guys have to try it out.
And we have a,
a war eagle and using some of their gums,
which is like a big eagle on a giant sword.
And uh,
so,
well the cool thing,
the cool thing,
the cool thing about the marine Raiders and about the marine special operations
is if you were in the navy,
in urine,
the seal teams,
like you have nothing.
There's no crowd,
there's almost no crossover.
There's almost no crime.
There's one,
there's 3% crossover from the B U s navy to a seal team in terms of your skills,
right?
You're a guy
driving a shipper working a big 16 inch gun or working on a missile technology.
That's what you do in the navy,
the seal teams,
you're in a field with a machine gun,
there's zero crossover and that's horrible.
And in the Marine Corps it's like,
Oh,
you're an infantry man.
That totally,
I mean every skill is applicable and that is such an advantage to the marine
corps and it's such an advantage to the Raiders because you get guys that have
fundamental infantry skills when they roll in.
We have to teach guys infantry skills.
Once we've taught them sort of fundamental special operations type,
small unit tactics,
then we have to teach them conventional,
more,
more conventional movements just to get them up to speed.
Because you got to know those things.
If you're out working with 140 Iraqi soldiers,
you can't,
that's,
that's not a small unit anymore.
You know,
you've got to go to think a little bit differently.
So you guys have that,
that advantage.
And that's an awesome and awesome thing.
I mean,
I remember the guys used to kind of complain about it when I was friends with a
bunch of force recon guys poking the do.
They would always complain about going to be billets like,
Hey,
I got to go,
well not to be built,
but they'd have to go back to an infantry platoon.
And I would always think to myself,
man,
I'd go to an infantry platoon.
Are you kidding me?
Like,
it's awesome.
It's awesome.
And so I think that's a,
as an advantage.
So if there's any young ones out there that are thinking about your future,
think about the Marine Corps because you get that full spectrum of kind of land
warfare.
You get the amphibious side too,
but you get the full spectrum of infantry and yeah,
and that's awesome.
And you don't want you,
it's hard to get that in the seal teams.
You get it over time.
But I got to where I got it from,
I got it from working with marines on our deployments and I got to see what a
company movement looked like.
And that's where I learned it from.
Thank God.
Cause by the time I was older and in Iraq working with the army and Marine
Corps,
I kind of had at least some semblance of knowledge about it.
Yeah,
yeah.
Couldn't agree more.
And one of the good things about that as well for us as an organization is,
um,
we don't have street to sof,
right.
There's a period of time.
And so,
you know,
like you get to assess people and one of the best assessments you can make for
future performances of past performance.
And so if you've already got two to four years of observation in the Marine
Corps,
if you couldn't hack it in and if triple t and then you don't really deserve to
try out or make it to the special libraries committee,
but those lessons learned,
you're absolutely right.
It's,
it's exactly the same stuff.
So if you,
you know,
like for all those young motivators out there,
they want to become a marine or become the mar soc like first,
first step is just become marine,
be good,
great marina at whatever you do.
You be an entry,
like be great,
like be the best rifle,
then you can be,
be the best motorman machine gunner or whatever else it is.
Any Mos.
Yes.
Okay.
So that's awesome.
So you don't have to worry about what your mom says.
You won't get withheld.
No.
It's becoming more and more competitive and,
and uh,
if you're smart,
obviously,
I mean I always tell people just going infantry or
reconnaissance units because you know,
if you want to be a raider and you want to go do those sorts of things,
those skillsets are much more applicable.
It's better,
learn them early and become a master of those as opposed to a master of Admin or
supply or anything else.
So what's Mos military operational specialty things.
So occupational specialty,
military.
So it's like what your job is,
got to be a rifleman.
You can be a machine gunner,
you can be a mortar men,
but you can also be an a mechanic.
You can be an it guy and you can be,
I mean there's marines that are due every job,
every job that you can have in a same thing in the army.
It's the same thing in the navy,
you know?
And so that's why it used to be in the navy,
you had to have certain ratings if you were going to go in the seal teams.
And so I was wondering if they did the same thing.
Like we only take guys from infantry.
Um,
last thing I'll ask you about,
because I know we've been here for awhile.
You got to go.
You've got two sons and how's that gone?
It's awesome.
How old are they?
Are Awesome.
They're almost 16 months old or 16 yeah,
16 months old.
Unless you're just in the full get some stage.
Yeah,
my wife is awesome.
So they can do a few things so they can run,
they can yell and they can throw things.
When I come home,
I just know that like she's been just getting run around getting thrown out and
I like yelled at cried diaper,
like the little thing.
And they're twins.
Yeah,
giants too.
He's got a twin brother.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they're giants.
They're huge.
Isn't there like psychological things to watch out for with twins?
Like wa?
I don't know.
Aren't they like hyper competitive?
Ah,
yeah.
Living away.
Let me give you one piece of advice.
I don't even,
I don't,
not a twin.
He's a twin.
Get your kids training Jujitsu when they're really young.
Because if you have a twin brother or even a brother that's close in age,
you're going to be really good at Jujitsu because you have a natural training
partner,
youtube with all the time.
They're the same size as you.
And there's some kids out there that are just sick and it's because they have
twins.
I mean,
I'm not just that,
I'm not trying to take away from them,
but it's a huge advantage if you've got a twin brother,
they should be grappling all lot.
I fully intend on that.
So that's one thing we didn't talk about,
but I love Jujitsu.
So I,
uh,
I got involved when I was a senior in high school.
It just became like a in Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Like did you wrestle?
I did a little bit of wrestling and then I played mostly football and Lacrosse
and uh,
one of the guys,
I was a lifeguard too.
And so one of the guys that came by pool,
uh,
he was,
like a correctional officer and got hooked up with Ah,
some guys up in Philadelphia and uh,
started training.
So it was like me,
him and a couple other guys turn it in like a,
a church gym and um,
it's a train there and then went to the naval.
One of the things that I did too was tried to start a Jujitsu club,
traveling club there.
Cause it was,
it was just coming up,
right.
I was like 2000,
two,
2000,
three,
2004 and so trained and then did uh,
did boxing dilemma May and um,
had a couple of fights and then like when it gradually became a marine and was
married was like put that on hold because I don't have time.
But yeah,
absolutely.
I going to have to walk up four kids.
I didn't put it on hold.
I got after it
fighting MMA fights on it.
No,
that's how I always have guys go,
well,
you know,
I,
once I had kids,
I got two kids and then they kind of give me the look.
The look for approval from my answer is I got four kids
get,
so you're already training anymore?
I'm not,
no,
no I haven't.
So I,
I uh,
I tried a little bit the marine corps,
you know,
we did some competitors and stuff and I did all that,
but I'm just focused on trying to do great infantry officer and so yeah.
Yeah.
Not going a friend Max Max Max is paralyzed.
Um,
chest down,
I would say.
Yeah.
He trains,
he trains,
had to come down and hook up with them sometime.
Yeah.
He's,
he's,
his grip has gotten a lot stronger.
Doing is all tight.
You know,
his grip is super strong now,
but um,
it's awesome.
But yeah.
Yeah.
No,
Jujitsu is a is good.
And with your twin boys it's going to be real good.
Um,
yeah man.
Look.
Aye.
I,
we've been here,
we've been at it for awhile and a man,
just,
just awesome.
Awesome to hear you and talk to you a w where can people find you?
So where should they look?
Twitter,
I'm on,
on Facebook,
Instagram,
Linkedin,
the usual,
uh,
Twitter,
all that stuff.
Derek.
Derek Herrera.
That's [inaudible] dot com there's two r's in a row in Herrera and there's a
third.
So there's a total of three rs in there and available.
Had had uh,
yeah,
but only one in your first name,
right?
Yeah,
first game.
Each GRE or a dotcom.
And so that's a website.
Uh,
I haven't updated the blog in a while.
Been focused on,
on work and just doing that.
And so spinal singularity.com has some of the other stuff we're doing.
But,
um,
Facebook,
Instagram,
all the stuff's public and put anything out that's not,
yeah,
that's not private and,
uh,
really to define me.
So I try to answer all the emails and messages and whatever else,
if anybody sends me notes.
So not hard to,
to track me down.
Awesome man.
Any,
uh,
and and Marine Raider foundation.org and can people find out how to donate on
their,
is that,
that'll take you over to that website at the top.
There's a donate button says donate now and uh,
they'll take you to a link.
You can mail checks,
you can sign up for credit card and paypal,
whatever,
whatever you do.
Um,
there's also some contact information too,
so if you can't,
can't give financial aid,
you want to give time.
There's volunteer opportunities for different events and things,
but um,
uh,
yeah,
that's great way to get involved.
Awesome.
You got any,
um,
any closing thoughts?
Yeah.
Uh,
thanks for having me.
It's a pleasure to be here and share my story with you.
I'm not here doing this to seek the limelight for anything.
I'm doing it to try to be a good ambassador of the guys that are continue to go
forward and put their,
their lives on the line on a daily basis,
um,
who can't talk about what they do or advocate for themselves.
Um,
a lot of people to think,
my wife in particular who's been there for me every step of the way.
Um,
the foundation,
the Marine Raider Foundation,
and all the people associated with,
with the organization,
uh,
my team who saved my life and wouldn't be here without them.
And uh,
you know,
all the guys that are out there continue to lay it down on a daily basis.
Awesome,
man.
Well,
like I said,
it's,
it's been an honor to sit here and talk to you and hear your story and what
you've been through and your sacrifice being be even beyond what you did in the
Marine Corps,
what you're still doing,
building your business and with the,
with the foundation and most important I think is just to set this incredible
example to this day of what it means to never surrender of what it means to
never quit and what it means to never give up regardless of the challenge that
you're facing.
Man,
that's awesome.
So I appreciate the example you set for me and for everyone and thanks for
coming on and sharing it a little bit.
Thank you.
Pleasure's all mine.
Awesome.
And Derek has left the building,
obviously.
Awesome to have him on and hear about his story.
So
Echo.
Yes.
If somebody wants to support this podcast,
how can they do it
anyways?
We will.
Well,
actually,
and I meant to kind of,
I didn't want to interrupt,
but you know,
the,
what do you call it?
The something d,
The decompression.
Needle down decompression.
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess I should ask him that,
but is that like,
can you feel that you know like when you know when it goes in because they can a
damn needle into you through your rib cage and into your lungs?
Yeah.
Remember you want to see if you can feel it.
I'll stick a needle through your chest.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I remember that movie three kings when they did that.
Mark Wahlberg.
Yes.
No,
they did that.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
Anyway.
All right.
You don't want to do like that movie.
Hey.
Yeah.
All right,
cool.
Anyway,
yes.
How can we support,
how can we support ourselves?
That's the question.
First way is to stay on the path.
Keep working out,
keep eating healthy.
That's the hardest one.
I mean,
Derek,
we're talking on a side note like eating healthy is kind of the hardest part
about this whole stain on the path page.
Could be.
Yeah,
I cause it's like the,
well then again,
working out can,
it depends on who you are.
Either way you want to stay on the path.
One of those elements of the path it's required now is Jujitsu.
True.
You agree,
right?
Yup.
Would anyway,
when you did you just say you're going to need a g,
go to origin main.com get whatever g you want.
Doesn't matter the color.
Oh,
no,
no.
Check with your instructor.
Getting ahead of myself.
Hey,
hey.
Check with your personal moral compass.
You W G that's not white.
Yeah.
So what do you mean tradition?
The tradition,
like,
yeah.
You know,
Pete consciously tries to,
like you serp my personality by,
he always,
he won't give me a white g.
He only gives me a blue g,
a black gay or whatever.
He wants to try and break me out of this tradition,
which he successfully done because now I have all different colored gies.
Yeah,
there you go.
But I wouldn't say that violates your moral situation.
That's more of a style thing.
Okay.
Which violates my,
yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah,
a little bit,
Huh?
Either way.
Yeah,
but I guess I can,
I can claim a small victory because I can be like,
oh,
I don't care what color it is.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's true.
Little,
little moral victory back in my direction,
cause nothing,
let it not like you're sitting around being like,
hey,
maybe I should grab up green gate cause that would make me like that.
That'd be awesome.
Just opening the package from Pete going,
Oh yeah,
he's going to be a blue Geek.
Whatever.
It's still on wearing.
Cool.
Thanks man.
Oh,
so yeah.
Get a gay man.
Whatever color you want.
After you checked with the instructor and your moral compass compass,
I guess I'm also rash guards.
Biggest selling g color is,
do you know white?
Nope.
Black.
Yes.
Dan,
come on.
We had this conference.
We had that conversation with Pete.
Everybody wants to be a Ninja.
Everybody wanted it to be an intern when they were little.
Oh,
I didn't know you were saying.
That's about the most selling.
I thought that that was like everybody wants to be a Ninja and it makes the
gete.
The Ninjas had a black geese apparently from what we know,
they had special shoes with the toe the night she goes
either way,
rash guards as you've got to swing rash guards for Nogi or for whatever kind of
activity.
You can get tee shirts there and you can get supplements Giacosa those
supplements during warfare for your joints.
Krill oil for your all around
hell discipline get you to get you in the zone.
Which JP,
I sent me a text and he's like,
how are you still saying Dave Burke is the rep?
Oh,
you're going to discipline these more because JP is more disciplined and he's on
discipline.
Go,
okay,
yeah that will go pill the discipline go pill and he's all,
he sent a picture of uh,
some like super high speed thing and he's like,
this is me on discipline.
Go
Jp is what he called jockeying for.
He wasn't playing goal representative position and he thinks Dave Burke cause
day Burke has sort of the Oji disciplined player.
Good deal.
Guilty.
Yeah,
he is.
Well,
it,
let's face it,
Dave Burke,
he's pretty,
he's going to be perfect regardless because he's such a like boom,
high achiever dude from day one,
you know,
so you know JP is a loose cannon so he can be the representative.
Well he can't be a loose cannon.
He's not.
He can be the representative discipline goal because he's disciplined.
But he'd go eat.
He goes,
I think the funny thing you don't mean loose cannon.
What you mean to say Jay about JP is JP.
He's fired up.
And what's funny is JP does need though disciplines.
That's why he's not the best representative.
Cause I'm like JP,
we're going to get more in the game.
He's in the game.
Yeah.
You need to.
So JP,
well we'll just give them a mutual support supporting assets behind the
discipline.
So yeah,
you can discipline,
you can also get milk,
milk,
chocolate,
peanut butter,
vanilla gorilla,
which is supposedly named after Leif Babin from what I understand.
And the darkness and other than the warrior kid milk,
strawberry and chocolate.
Try those out.
Even if you're an adult.
I hate to say it but I was thinking about this.
Have you ever as an adult drink a strawberry quick?
Yes.
You have.
I have big time.
Yeah.
Well now we don't have to do that anymore because now you can get something
that's literally completely healthy.
What was the one there was like that wasn't quick that they tried to skew or
angle is healthy,
right?
That was,
they couldn't do that.
Some other ones,
some other chocolate.
I know onto that.
Yeah.
I forget it had vitamin and then the only tried the work in multi level team.
They might try and skew.
That's all.
Come on and go look at the ingredients and then we'll compare that to two Malke.
Yeah.
You know what that stuff has in it.
A bunch of sugar.
You know mark hasn't it?
Moke
direct from bulk.
I dig it.
So yeah,
get all that stuff from origin may not come.
Yeah.
Also if you want to represent Jocko has a store.
Everybody Christmas is coming up.
This is what I'm doing.
I'm going to activate.
It's funny cause I'm saying it like this is new thing.
It's just like such an old think a gift card
gift card on Jocko store.com.
So it's like,
you know,
like okay your brother or whoever doesn't,
it's like in the game,
I don't know.
Well you know,
whatever your cousin,
whoever,
and they're in the game,
they want,
you know,
and you say,
Hey,
you know what?
I can't pick out what I want for you from here.
You just pick out what you want.
Bolton.
There you go.
Gift Card.
Boom.
Nonetheless.
You know what?
I'm leaving this completely in your hands.
You know why I don't give gifts,
I don't like gifts and gift cards just aren't a thing for me.
I've never given anyone a gift card ever.
And so that's going to be your deal over there on your side of the tracks.
That's exactly what I was thinking when I was making it.
I was like,
okay,
this goes against kind of Jocko thinks that you don't want me to do on the gift
card.
Uh,
virtual representation.
I'm going to put your face right in the middle of it.
Boom.
That's what I did.
So there you go on it.
So it's Kinda like,
yeah,
it's a gift card,
but it's kind of from Jocko.
Since you don't give gifts,
boom.
There you go.
Anyway,
on there there's some good shirts you want to represent.
Discipline equals freedom,
you know,
any kind of,
how should I say,
philosophy and the path.
Some good stuff on there.
Some rash guards as well.
And hoodies,
tank tops.
I know it's winter,
I dig it.
But if you're in Honolulu,
Pearl Harbor,
wherever you can still represent the tank top this time of year.
Um,
but yeah,
a lot of good stuff on there.
Jocko store,
Dotcom,
deaf of course stuff to the core.
Also subscribe to subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't already on stitcher,
iTunes,
Google play and
Spotify.
And I listen to Spotify,
I barely know what it is,
but I hear good things and you know,
we're on there and you know what it Spotify play like mixed tapes kind of.
Is that the theory behind it?
I don't know man.
Yeah.
I don't know either.
You can get the podcast there as well.
He can,
yeah,
you can ask Alexa for the podcast.
A Lek.
Okay.
And don't be confused with that.
I think we went over this before.
Some people think that it's an Alexa,
not Alexa.
That's like saying I have,
it's not an iPhone,
it's a Siri.
No,
Siri is the the girl inside Alexis,
the girl inside the device called Amazon Echo check later.
Anyway.
Yes.
I'm the five to see if you haven't already and leave a review.
If you're in the mood.
Don't forget about the warrior kid podcast,
which I just posted a new one last week and got a lot of really cool uh,
feedback on that one.
And
Yeah,
I think once people got that one,
cause I don't talk about it,
I don't post very much about it.
But anyways,
a bunch of people downloaded all of them because they're,
they're cool and they're good.
I believe the word is conversation starters with your children.
That's what a lot of people said.
Like,
oh,
I finally had the conversation that I needed to have with my kids about,
well in that case,
warrior kid podcast number 19 about making good decisions and making bad
decisions and how if you make some bad decisions along the way,
you could ruin everything.
Yeah,
yeah,
totally.
And you,
what's interesting about that one too is I have the supreme luxury of being able
to listen to all of these wild,
they happen,
right?
These podcasts.
But on top of that,
if I have a specific question for myself,
I can just ask you do you know?
But like even though I might already kind of know the answer,
but when you deal with kids,
you can't just deliver certain information the same way you would as an adult,
like your friends.
So I'm like,
man,
how do I approach this specific situation?
And the way that,
and the way you do it in warrior kid is the same way.
Like you,
you kind of tell it to me or whatever.
It's that alleviates so much stress when like when you need to approach your
kids with this skin stuff.
Or one thing that everyone says is this is what I try and tell my kids.
They don't listen to me,
which is exactly what I'm talking about.
They listened to uncle did no one listen to me that this not uncle Jake.
Let Uncle Jake tell him what's what Uncle Jake speaks the truth and they and
they accept it from Uncle Jake.
Yeah.
Oddly enough.
Yes sir.
Also youtube if you like,
if you were interested in the video version of this podcast,
you to see what [inaudible] looks like.
You got to do with Derek,
looks like,
let me see what I look like.
If that's your thing.
If you haven't seen the two minute trailer for the Mikey and the dragons book,
you can get that on youtube,
which by the way is epic and I don't use that term lightly.
It's cool.
Echo sent me the for approval text with that radio in it and I watched it and I
wrote back,
this is the best video I've ever seen in my entire life.
All caps.
Yeah.
Good.
And then I went and read youtube comments so far.
No one has said echoes Jack,
cause you're not in the video.
Yeah.
Which is,
which is Supreme Lee.
Cool.
But no,
what's cool is people are,
are saying about a two minute video,
a cartoon video about a kid's book.
People are saying that they got tears in her eyes that they got chills.
It's a legit video.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
So yeah,
you can get that if you go to the youtube channel and then while you're doing
that you can subscribe to it to,
to the youtube channel if you want.
Get the big,
you know,
subscriptions.
And then you can also,
you can get,
you can get psychological warfare from iTunes,
Google play,
MP three,
whatever.
And that's me telling you to do the right thing and making you do it.
Yeah.
So just give it a shot through it.
True.
Also,
when you want to vary up your workout,
you want to add kettle bells to your workout,
get on at kettle bells,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko some good stuff on their workout stuff.
A lot of good stuff on it.
Good information too,
by the way.
So go in there on it.com/jocko Jocko white tea.
Yes,
tastes delicious and is very good for you and it gives you an 8,000 pound dead
lift.
So give that one a try.
I also got some books.
We got
Mike in the dragons.
Okay,
update.
I am printing them as fast as I can.
There's a bunch of printers that are printing new copies of Mike and the
dragons.
Some of them are already been shipped.
There'll be going to Amazon.
We are going to be cutting it close right now.
Actually.
We should be good people that are ordering well.
It's going to be cutting costs depending on when you exactly order,
whether it gets you by Christmas or not.
But the faster you order,
the better chance you will have of getting it before Christmas.
I apologize that I did not order enough books to be printed and that is my fault
and I should have done better.
And as Sarah Armstrong pointed out to me,
she's like,
Oh yeah,
well you know why you didn't order enough books cause you thought,
oh well Sarah will get a book.
And Andrew Paul,
we'll get a book and I also get a book and then everyone posts with,
they got,
Andrew got 20 copies.
Sarah got 10 copies of Iris,
got 10 cops.
So everyone's buying multiple copies because it's the ultimate Christmas gift
for anyone between the ages of zero and 10 or 12 anyways,
Mike in the dragons,
order it as quick as you can and we will try and get it to you by Christmas.
If not,
hey,
uh,
what's the next holiday after Christmas?
New Years.
Okay.
Maybe they'll get a new kid and here's gift and or what's after that Easter?
Well,
technically the Easter.
Oh,
well technically,
okay.
You get Valentine's Day gift for your children,
I guess.
Do.
You should do that and if not,
you know,
just get it for him.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
That's a fun one that you mentioned,
that video,
the goal there was to kind of sent,
try to capture what it's like,
like reading,
you know how long you would read a book he goes on in your head and so you
capture what's going on in that book in your head.
How you're reading it to your key.
Kind of capture that in a little summary.
That's what it was.
I think it did because that's really how I felt when I read that book to my
daughter.
It's good that you do voices.
When you'd read that book.
Let me hear the king voice.
Come on man.
I'm not going to hurt mine to my song Yak cause it really is,
but rather is classified so you got to at least just give us a to my son.
Too Much Sun.
That was all fine.
It sounds way better when I read a terror.
Understand that.
Wow.
I also,
and I feel like a voice actor over here compared to that one.
You kind of,
Oh hey,
moving on.
Yeah.
Mike and the dragons.
Awesome book.
Also way of the warrior kid.
One end to from wimpy to warrior kid and then Mark's mission.
That's number one.
Number two,
also important critical books.
I personally think,
or the one that my daughter requests me to read again and again and again is
part to mark Mark's mission.
That's interesting.
She really likes Nathan,
Nathan James.
She likes that idea of that irritating person because that's how kids are.
They always talking,
you know,
wait until she meets Danny Reinhart,
Danny Reinhardt book three.
I'm in the process of writing right now.
10 chapters deep.
Danny Reinhart shows up.
So yeah,
she'll,
she'll any Reinhart even though my youngest daughter,
we're not,
when she found out about the character Danny Reinhardt and who he was,
and now she goes,
Tanny Reinhart
cause the character,
he's like good at everything.
That's the premise of warrior kid three the,
there's no bully per se.
There's actually a kid that's a good kid.
He's good at Jujitsu,
he's good at pull ups,
he's good at running,
he's good at everything and he's nice.
And that Rob's marked the wrong way because all of a sudden he's got someone
that he's jealous of it and his ego.
And what's that guy's name?
His name is Danny Ryan.
How awesome is that?
So like,
what am I told my daughter that she was like Danny Reinhardt and she says,
oh,
she says what a Danny Reinhardt do today.
But at well you kind of can anticipate that your son or daughter that you're
reading it to,
or the person reading the,
you know,
if they're of a reading age,
they're going to like Danny Reinhardt.
They are,
but they're,
I don't know if they're going to,
they might,
they might side with Mark A.
Little bit.
Cause you can hear Mark's getting annoyed cause Danny just heal.
He does this,
he taps heel,
tap someone out and say like,
ah,
you know,
I must have got lucky.
He's one of those kind of guys were like,
he beats him in a running race and he's like,
Oh yeah,
you know,
I was,
I was feeling pretty good today.
I guess guys,
he won't take credit for anything,
which is,
and,
and since it's already bothers mark that he lost,
he said yeah.
And plus we all been on the mission since,
you know,
be since before mark could even do pullups we've been with them the whole time,
so we're feeling his pain with them.
So now this guy,
Danny,
he hasn't felt any pain.
Forget,
they just naturally good at everything.
I screw that guy.
Yeah.
So that's Danny Reinhart and that's going to be coming out in the spring.
Hopefully if I finish it in time,
but which I will discipline equals freedom field manual.
You can get that book too.
That's another book that you can get for the holiday season is,
let's just say that if it,
it might kind of mess up like jam up someone's New Year a little bit if they try
and get on the path.
Like for Christmas,
like what pre New Year's resolutions scenario.
Yeah.
Oh,
maybe they,
maybe they use that to kick off the new year's resolution.
They get a little deathcore.
Yeah,
but here's the thing though.
I think you might even say it in that book.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
I've said,
oh,
new years now.
I've said that many times and I believe it's to this moment.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that's the district was greenfield manual.
The,
the audio version of that is not an audible,
it is on,
it's an MP.
Three thing.
Itunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
extreme ownership.
That's the first leadership I wrote book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin.
We followed that up with the dichotomy of leadership,
which is possibly better anyways.
You should check it out.
It will teach you how to pragmatically apply the policies,
put forth in extreme ownership into your
world.
We also have a leadership consultant company.
We saw prompts to leadership.
That's what we do.
It's me,
Lafe,
Bab and JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
Mike's Rally,
Mike,
bye Ma and if you want to find out about that,
go to Ashkelon front.com we will come out and work with your company and get
your leadership aligned.
Also,
we've got to muster in 2019 there's going to be one in Chicago,
there's going to be one in Denver and if you want to come to the monster,
they've all sold out.
So if you want to come try and register early extreme ownership.com and we have
e f Overwatch,
which connects Spec ops vets
and aviation combat aviation vets with companies that need leaders,
tried and tested leaders and any you mar soc Raiders out there that have gotten
out.
He headed up at eff,
overwatch.com and we can get you connected to a job where you will be in a
leadership position in the civilian sector.
Again,
that's,
you have overwatch.com if you want to hang with us still after this on the
interwebs.
Uh,
first of all,
Derek,
like I said,
he left but Twitter,
Derek Herrera,
Instagram,
uh,
Derek underscore Herrera,
Facebook,
Derek Herrera,
Derek herrera.com and also the Marine Raider Foundation.
Again,
he talked about all the things that the Marine Raider Foundation does and if you
want to go to that,
the link is a Marine Raider foundation.org.
And then of course if you want to talk with the echo and myself on Twitter,
on Instagram or on Facebook,
d Baja Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And thanks to all our military personnel out there holding the line,
we can do what we do because you are doing what you do and we will never forget
that.
And special thanks to the Marine Raiders for your legacy of bravery that will
never be forgotten.
And obviously Derek Herrera for his service,
his sacrifice.
And like I said to him,
the incredible example that he sets thanks to policing,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT is correctional officer's border patrol,
all first responders.
Thank you for keeping us safe here at home.
And the rest of you that are out there listening,
I know things don't always go the way we want them to go,
but I think just listening to Derek today,
I think there's no doubt that that is the attitude you take.
You don't focus on what is wrong.
You focus on what is right.
You don't focus on what you can't do.
You focus on what you can do.
You're thankful that you have these opportunities.
That's so many didn't get.
Then you take that attitude and then you go out there and get after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.